wealth breakthroughs is an exclusive
video series where millionaires break
their silence on their usually hidden
secrets on how to stack up great wealth
it's like eavesdropping on the private
conversations Rich folks have with each
other behind closed doors but I
partnered with the series Creator Jeff
Hayes to bring that VIP pass to you
right here today in this episode you'll
learn the Peter Lynch secret of making a
fortune why buying a business is better
than starting one how to eliminate debt
quickly and how to take control of your
money don't miss this episode if you're
serious about getting on the track of
living your dream life
enjoy welcome back to episode three of
wealth breakthroughs today we have two
absolutely larger in Life personalities
for you Kenny pcar spent over 30 years
on Wall Street and today you can catch
him numerous times a week on CNBC he's
forgotten more about profitable
investing than most of us will ever know
and Carl Allen who's completed billions
worth of business Acquisitions in his
career will show you why starting a
business might be one of the biggest
mistakes of your life that's right
Carl's an absolute Master at gaining
control of businesses someone else
starts and makes profitable if you know
the right way and the right moment to
pounds you can buy profitable businesses
without putting a nickel of your own
money on the line we'll get to Carl in a
moment first let's check in with Kenny a
natural Storyteller and like I said a
true Larger than Life personality
Kenny's ready to share the Peter Lynch
secret to making a fortune Lynch as you
might know is one of the greatest
investors of the past 100 years he
averaged returns of
29.2% per year and all this success can
be distilled down into one little known
secret Kenny's about to share listen
closely your wealth breakthrough could
be right around the corner here's
[Music]
Kenny Kenny thanks for braving these
Downtown City elements it's a little
noisy around here but uh that's okay we
can uh we can talk through the noise uh
so tell us about your background how did
you get into doing what you're
doing well I was in uh my freshman year
in college and I had the opportunity to
go work as a summer inter summer intern
on the floor of the New York Stock
Exchange which uh I was a kid from
Boston I had every intention of going
back to Cap Cod and being a lifeguard on
the beach at 19 years old I had no
intention of moving to New York City in
the middle of the summer like it didn't
make sense to me yet I thought about it
you know my first reaction was to say no
I'm not interested uh and then I thought
about it over spring semester my
freshman year and I decided you know
what's the worst that's going to happen
the worst going to happen I'm going to
go there I'm going to have this
experience I'm not going to I like it
I'll chalk it up for experience and move
on or I'm going to go there and it's
going to change the course of my life
and in fact it changed the course of my
life it was the most dramatic exciting
place I had ever been to and I had never
been there before right I was a kid from
Boston I didn't grow up around the New
York Stock Exchange I didn't know what
the New York Stock change was I didn't
know a buy from a sell a stock from a
bond an E from a quarter nothing and uh
that first summer which was a summer
1980 and I was 19 years old and I moved
to downtown New York City on Gold Street
which was that was like the financial
District so there was nothing going on
there rents were cheap um but the place
was empty meanwhile I moved in and uh
went to work on the floor of the
exchange not really knowing anything and
and spent that first summer as really an
intern you know as a gopher right go for
coffee go for this write reports kind of
learn talk to people read and so that's
what I did but I have to tell you I I
got there in May of 1980 uh and by the
middle of June it it just bit me on the
backside it was the most exciting listen
5,500 type a personal personalities all
in one room you can imagine the energy
level was up here every single day no
matter what the market was doing and in
1980 remember we had just come through
the Jimmy Carter years the economy was a
disaster Ronald Reagan had just become
president interest rates were high
unemployment was high inflation was high
and so it was not the best time in the
world to be in financial services um and
nor was the market real was the market
really in a good place right the da was
trading in the 800s but yet for me as a
19-year-old kid it was the most exciting
place in the world because everybody
down there was a street smart kid from
they were from the Burrows right from
Manhattan from Queens from Brooklyn from
Staten Island but they were they were
like Street kids right my generation
really was the first generation that had
any formal education Beyond High School
um and and that's not a negative that
was just the way kind of the world
worked right because on the floor of the
exchange is it's you had to have it in
your belly you had to have you had to be
Street Smart you had to know how to play
you had had to know how to play poker
right because you had to know how to
represent yourself and you didn't learn
that in college right right you learned
that from being from being Street Smart
you learned that by having a a very
aggressive type eight personality it was
it was it was really unbelievable and so
uh that's how it started and then uh
that summer it I didn't want to leave by
the time August came uh but it was time
to go back to college and I wanted to go
to college so I went back but I I got
the opportunity to come back every
summer 82 and then the summer of 83
which was really the defining summer of
of this whole experience because in 1983
now we were well into the Reagan
presidency they had just passed the tax
reform bill so we were in the middle of
this kind of uh sea change in the
economy interest rates were 21% interest
rates were 21% unemployment was 133%
inflation was running at 10% it was a
disaster in this country right and guys
kids getting out of college couldn't get
a job and guys who were my age then were
getting thrown out the same way that we
saw during the great financial crisis
when we went through that when we went
through that that disaster but I went
back in the summer of 1983 for the guy
that I had worked for this independent
broker I had worked for in the summer of
81 882 and things were so bad that uh
that this guy couldn't even afford to
have me now understand I was making $125
a week to be a summer intern for this
guy but it was just the extra $125 that
he just it just it wasn't in the budget
right and the Dow was trading at 892 and
we might have traded 30 million shares a
day
today we trade 30 million shares in
about a minute and a half that's the
difference right because we did it in a
day and you did it all by pen and paper
and so I thought to myself in the summer
of 1983 when I came back that okay maybe
this is the summer I'm gonna go be
lifeguard on the beach because you know
he ba I came there and he basically
couldn't have me but by this time I had
gotten to know a number of people on the
floor other Brokers and so I went around
saying hello to people and this I went
over to this one other broker who who is
ass salt of the earth he's I love this
man and uh you know he puts his arm
around me welcomes me back and how you
doing and how is school and what are you
doing and I said listen everything's
great other than Doug can't afford to
have me this summer right I mean his
business is bad and so it's just another
expense he can't have I said so I'm just
kind of looking around to see if there's
another opportunity before I decide to
go back be a lifeguard on the beach so
he puts his arm around me and uh he said
to me hey kid do you know the symbol for
IBM yes IBM he said you know do you know
the difference between a buy and a sell
yes sir you know differ between eighth
and a quarter I go I think so he goes
how's 225 a week are you kidding me I
just got a raise I it was it was the
greatest day of my life I said when can
I start like right now and so and so I
that's that's what I did in the summer
1983 I work for this other guy and his
business was actually different he was
actually doing a lot of business because
he did a lot of the option layoff
business which was which was becoming
part of the financial services
experience so he was in the right place
at the right time and uh so I was there
during the summer 1983 and the most
dramatic thing that happened and some
people that are watching this will
remember it others won't was what
happened on Tuesday August 17th and it
was a Tuesday morning and on the Monday
afternoon on the 16th there was this
rumor that went around the industry kind
of the floor it was coming down through
through uh different Brokers on on the
on the phones that there was going to be
the surprise announcement on Tuesday
Morning from the fed well here was the
deal the FED never made surprise
announcements the FED came out at 8:30
on Thursday mornings they open the door
they stepped out they told you what they
did they turned around they closed the
door they didn't sit there and hold your
hand and give you a Xanax and say you
okay with this let's talk about it
nothing they they came out they said
what they said they walked in it was up
to the market to figure out what was
next right and so the idea that the Fed
was going to come out with the surprise
announcement on Tuesday Morning made no
sense to anybody because the FED never
did that so remember this is 1983
there's no internet there's no
television on the floor there's no radio
there's no there there's no outside
sources to poison the mind on the floor
everything we got came from the phones
people outside that would call down and
tell you what happened in the world
right
it was really spectacular and so as
Tuesday Morning came as we approached
8:30 you know there were there were
5,000 people on the floor and so it was
typically a noisy kind of boisterous
place but as we approached 8:30 that
morning I'll never forget it the room
kind of got quiet because everyone was
waiting to see if there was this
surprise announcement coming and at
about 8:30 and 30 seconds every single
phone on the floor lit up and they were
the old fashioned phones the metal
phones with the push buttons that would
ring a ring like a ring today they sing
songs and they do all that stuff but
they were like it was like a ring right
and every phone lit up and it felt like
Christmas because when you picked up the
phone everyone on the other side was
like did you see what happened you said
no I didn't see what happened what
happened because you couldn't see what
happened and what happened was Paul vul
who was fed share came out made this
announcement that he was cutting
interest rates by 10% now when Ray to
21% 10% was a huge move it was two full
percentage points and so that was the
birth of the bull market right August
17th 1982 was really the birth of what
then became a 25-year bull market and he
drew the Line in the Sand that day that
he rates were coming down he was going
to break the back of unemployment break
the back of inflation he was going to
force money out of the banks and into
the market because look if you were
anyone who had any money at all if you
could take your money and go to the bank
and get 21% guaranteed riskless sleep at
night or you go out and you buy American
companies which are beautiful beautiful
compan Johnson and Johnson General
Electric all great companies but there's
risk in those companies and so listen
you you have to balance it out do I buy
something that's risky or do I put my
money in the bank at 21% 21% think about
that for one minute guaranteed and sleep
at night right so all this money was in
the banks and so when he came out with
this announcement he lit that fire the
money started coming out of the banks
and into the market and the market
exploded and that day what was really
amazing the market was up 4 and a half
per. well 4 and a half% was 35 points
yeah but it was it wasn't the 35 points
it was the 42% today 42% would be you
know would be 1500 points or whatever
the number is right I mean it would be D
and and on Monday we traded 30 million
shares all by hand and on Tuesday we
traded 138 million shares in the same
six- hour time span all on pen and paper
it was those the most amazing day like I
I can remember it like it was yesterday
and that's what got me into it I mean I
just I just I couldn't stand it anymore
it was so exciting for me but had to go
back to my senior in college do you miss
those days I do I miss those days
tremendously because that was really the
guts of the place it was the people it
was the excitement it was the energy it
was the personalities that made the
place what it was right and it was the
time in this country it was the time in
in the century when everything was just
starting to click and and and the world
was you know the world was Ablaze and
great economic prosperity and certainly
this country though that was the
beginning of the turnaround it was the
most amazing place in the world I
couldn't wait I couldn't wait to get up
I jumped out of bed at 4:00 every
morning I couldn't wait to get there
because every day was a different day
and the energy in the room like I said
you take 5,000 Ty a personalities and
put them all in one room yeah and then
you tell me what the energy level is
right and if the Market's up the energy
is up here if the Market's down the
energy is up here it's a different
energy but you can feel it you know like
when you go to a concert and you're
standing in front of the speakers and
they play the music and the and the
music just goes right through you you
can feel it in every bone in your body
it was like that every single day it was
the most amazing place in the whole
world how's it different now well it's
very automated M the very 21st century
that's great wonderful very efficient uh
but the people are all gone right
because the automation that's what
automation does I mean who's kidding who
so you don't have that craziness going
on in the floor exchange there's no
craziness going on and and it's not I
don't mean that to be in a bad way
because it's very modern it's very 21st
century it's very efficient it is still
the New York Stock Exchange it is still
at the very core of capitalism it's just
different right it's evolved but what
what's happened as a result of the
technology is that 5,300 people are gone
there's 200 people left 225 people maybe
left on the floor of the exchange as
members right as as men and women that
are actually helping to to trade stock
and make markets and that's not it's not
a negative on the exchange it's evolving
right that that's technology just forced
that Evolution not only here but around
the world because exchanges around the
world are like that right most of the
most of the human beings uh that that
sat in those positions are no longer
there because the technology has been
replaced and so today it's a it's a
vastly different place in that sense but
it's still you know it's still at the
very heartbeat of American capitalism
you made the transition from the old
days into the the modern world I did are
there a lot of people that didn't well
yes but there's a number of reasons why
right because as we were making that
transition as you came into the um into
the 90s was really it was really the
conversation started kind kind of in the
early 90s because here was the deal the
us out of the three major Market centers
Asia Europe and the us we're by far the
biggest Market Center out of all three
of them but yet the other centers had
already automated they automated back in
the late 80s and very early 90s so they
were already trading in decimals they
were already trading and using
technology the us the biggest Capital
Market in the world we're still trading
with 5,500 people pen to paper face to
face eights and quarter of a dollar
right and it's now 1992 93 and so the
conversation about uh what the future
was going to look like uh was all about
technology but yet now it's 1992 93 and
what was going to happen seven years out
was this thing called Y2K that you know
had the world Ablaze because remember
those conversations about the world was
going to collapse and GPS was going to
fall and satellites were going to fail
and planes were going to fall out of the
sky and utilities weren't going to pump
water right because the computer was
written the co the way the code was
written the date was written in two
decimal places so you know it was 99 and
so when we went from from 1231 99 to 110
the computer start were going backwards
and not forwards and everything was
going to fail and so there was this rush
around the world not only in this
country was really around the world
about upgrading technology whether you
upgraded it whether you replaced it and
so being a tech investor or being in the
being on the floor of the exchange
during that time was was tremendously
exciting just because there was so much
happening around the world and so this
country made a decision partly because
there were only seven years to go before
we hit Y2K and look seven years a long
time but when you've got to completely
take the US capital market system and
Destroy every handwritten rule that was
written in the SEC acts of 3334 and then
rewrite automated rule sets and put it
out there for comment and then make sure
everybody can connect and make sure that
the that the information travels back
and forth the right way 7 years is not a
long time and so and so partly it was by
Design the country made the decision
that we would clearly start to move
ahead and so that was all being done
kind of in the background and we
continued to trade pend paper eight of a
dollar then 16 of a dollar as we got
closer to the year 2000 until we went
through the turn of the century cuz look
if we went through the turn of the
century and the and the and the
technology failed guess who's going to
be standing there going we're okay was
the United States because we're still
doing this the rest of the world was
doing it automatically and if they if it
failed they were the ones that were
going to get that were going to get hurt
not us right and so there was a little
method to that Madness but the minute we
went through Y2K and the world didn't
fall apart then the push to automate
really hit the US markets and so the
transition began you know it began soon
after uh 2000 probably March or so of
2000 when they started to decimalized
because in order to use technology you
had to decimalized so what's
incomprehensible is that 5,500 people
are are face to face you know
unbelievable it worked in other words no
mistakes you know things settled at the
end of the day uh things settled listen
there were you would hear the occasional
mistake but the occasional mistake came
became very expensive yeah and so once
you made a really expensive mistake you
didn't make that mistake again right so
it was it was trial by fire but the
sense is the most amazing part is that
yes with all those people with what
appeared to be so chaotic as an outsider
looking in was not chaotic at all it was
it was in my mind it was very efficient
it was very exciting and you know you
just multitask I could be in three
different stocks at once and I could be
you know I could be standing with you
and Coke but listening to what's going
on in IBM or listening to what's going
on in Delta Airlines and and and and
able to react to whatever I heard
because that's the way it was and this
is why you're saying Street Smart kids
were the ones who could do that not
necessarily the ivy league graduate
that's coming in right because you
because you know you didn't learn this
in college you go to college and you
learn principles and economic economic
theory great wonderful it's not what you
did on the floor of the exchange at all
you had to be able to react when I had
an order from a client then listen
clients were not retail we're not
talking about going in and buying 100
shares of Coke or 50 shares of of
telephone for your kids retirement
account you're talking about
representing institutions asset managers
mutual funds hedge funds pension plant
foundations that need to buy a million
shares of Coke or 200,000 shares of IBM
and so when you walked into the crowd
you had to be able to read the crowd you
had to be able to understand what your
client wanted to do because my client
could have been on the other side of the
country but at the moment he was sitting
here right on my shoulder right because
in my in my hand there was an order I
got to buy 150,000 IBM and here are the
parameters that he or she wants to buy
it under he told me that she told me
that so when I walked into the crowd I
knew that information I knew what I
needed to do but now I had to assess
what the crowd was doing and what the
market was doing what the stock was
doing what the total Market was doing
maybe what one of the competitors in
this industry was doing that might
affect what I'm doing right so you had
to synthesize all that information and
you had to walk into a crowd and you had
to ask the questions which was another
reason technology wouldn't have worked
at the time because so much of it was
driven by the conversation that you and
I had that he and I had that she and I
had based on I'd walk into a crowd and
I'd say how's IBM and the special would
represent his interest but then he might
say to me I've got two buyers and a
seller and so it was up to me to then
have that conversation with all the
participants so then I could understand
what the market was and so that's where
all the information was that's what made
it the most dramatic exciting place in
the world because it was anyone that
wanted to buy and sell IBM at that
moment in time had to be standing there
they had to be there and they had to
participate and if you said nothing then
you weren't included if I walked in and
I said what are you doing IBM and you
said you you have nothing to do then you
have nothing to do so then if I go if I
am I'm a buyer and I go take the stock
at a quarter you go I can sell 50 at a
quarter no no no you didn't offer
anything I'm taking the 50 from him
because you didn't you didn't open your
mouth right so I didn't know you were
there he opened his mouth so guess what
I trade with him now it's your offer
afterwards if you still want to make an
offer but so it like a code of conduct
it was a code of conduct but that's what
made it the place it was because it was
understood that there was this code of
contact and everybody operated and
everybody understood the code of contact
so now it's gotten sterilized right I
mean there's sterilized is Yeah it's
gotten neutered Yeah it's gotten
sterilized for sure because none of that
conversation exists anymore because it's
all automated and you can't talk to the
computer right and the computer doesn't
react and you know people always thought
that it was the boys club that you know
you and I were buddies and so wink wink
you know it's not the way it was at all
because I had a client to represent you
had a client to represent you and I
could be the best of friends but guess
what between 9:30 and 4:00 if we had to
go head-to-head we went head to head
because you were representing your
client and I was representing mine I'm
trying to get the best price for my
buyer you're trying to get the best
price for your seller so you're
interacting with all the other people in
the crowd and so therefore it was
dramatic it was so unbelievable and then
at four o'clock no matter what happened
during the day we could have been going
head to-head all day and at 4:00 I say
you come let's go out for a beer cuz
that's just the way it was it was this
camaraderie it was this collegiality
that was didn't exist anywhere in the
world so uh I'm I'm just curious how a a
a timid introvert like you got the job I
timid and introverted you weren't there
I mean you would have gotten run over
right you would have gotten run over if
you were timid introverted there was
nobody timed introverted now maybe they
weren't listen I'm very excitable yeah
maybe they weren't as excitable as me
but they were not type B personal
everyone was a type A you know I mean I
met my wife on the floor of the exchange
my wife was a member of the New York
Stock Exchange at a time when there were
you know eight or 10 women who were
physically members like running around
the floor as physical members there were
women who were quote unquote members
because you have to understand the
difference if if if if you and your wife
were married and you owned a seat on the
New York Stock Exchange it had to be in
one person's name so it might be in your
name but if you passed away that's an
asset then would then pass to your wife
so now the seats in her name she becomes
the
member but she's not the working member
see there's a difference
M were who were MERS because they owned
a seat they didn't work it so my wife
was one of the working members on the
floor and at a time it was 1984 when she
became a member and women were just
banging their heads on the ceiling like
you know in the late 70s yeah uh how
many total members are there in the
stock exchange well then there were 1366
members and then the other 4,000 people
were all support right right today there
are 20 250 maybe well and all the
support people are gone because the
technology have evolved if uh you know
for the typical person out there in the
world is now uh they have more
opportunity to earn money in the in the
market or was it better back then for
them no in that sense the the game
hasn't changed the market is still the
market and and and the capital markets
serve a function right because they
allow people to participate they allow
the average American to be able to buy
stock in US companies as well as
International companies now that trade
on the fla exchange and invest their
money to generate wealth and income for
generations and so that opportunity
hasn't changed that opportunity is still
there the difference the difference
though today is there's so much more
noise today than there was partly
because in the 80s and 90s when there
were only seven price points it was an
E8 quarter 385 78 between every full
figure that's all there was today
there's a thousand price points because
the exchanges trade in two decimals so
that's 100 price points right A Penny to
99 Cents but then the dark pools the
alter venues the internalization engines
trade out four decimal places so they
can trade out at
0.00001 all the way up to 9999 which
creates a thousand price points with
every full figure and so therefore that
has is what's caused a lot of the noise
when you say no what do you mean by
noise well noise what I mean is is is
noise in the market noise in the way
stocks trade right when we traded in
eights of a dollar and seven price
points it was very defined you would see
block box of stock trade 20,000 would
traded a half 50,000 would traded 38
50,000 would Trad at a half again and so
you could see volume around price and so
there was less noise today because
there's a thousand price points and
because it's all algorithmically driven
what you don't see anymore is you don't
see the big prints because nobody prints
50,000 or 100,000 shares anymore right
they take their order and they break it
down into 100 share units and they spray
the market across the the 11 exchanges
plus the 50 different alternative venues
that now exist they spray the so
everyone's trading in small lots and so
the noise is that's the noise because
you don't you can't you know there was
an art to reading the tape you know back
in the 80s and 90s when you would see
the ticket tape go by you'd see the
volume and the prices and if you were a
good Trader you could read the tape you
understood where the market was going
you understood where that stock was
going you understood where where the
sector is you would see you know you
would see IBM and and and and other tech
stocks you know trading up you would see
that there was demand you could tell by
by the tape today it's more difficult to
see because the way the because the way
the noise that's created by the multiple
hundred share prints you can't really
read it anymore right so yeah so does it
so for an investor now that wants to
come in and say hey I want to I want to
trade this Market I want to see if I can
invest trade what have you are they
going to be eaten up by these tech
people who know how to get in there and
do this or no so that's a great question
but here's what I would say to an
investor because there's a difference
between an investor and a Trader right
an investor you have a much different
time Horizon on your hand you have a
much different plan right you're
Investing For Something in the future
whether it's your retirement 30 years
out whether it's for some wedding
whether it's to buy a house but you're
you're investing for a longer period of
time and so what that person needs to do
is eliminate that noise they can't pay
attention to the to to the Daily
machinations of what the trader wants to
do what the algorithms are doing they
have to say look I'm here's my goal
here's how I have to do it I like
Coca-Cola and I like GE and I like IBM
and I like Intel and apple whatever they
like and then they put the plan together
and then they and then they methodically
follow that plan whether the Market's up
or down they methodically follow it now
look if you want to allocate $1,000 a
month okay and the markets on one month
you know Apple's trading at a high okay
so you're going to take the th000 you're
going to buy a$ th000 worth of Apple
next month if if Apple's come under
pressure now it's trading down 10 points
you're going to take that same ,000 and
still buy a $1,000 of Apple except
you're going to buy more apple right
because the price is lower so over time
you know you average you know you you
get an average in prices and so that's
how you really build a portfolio now if
you're talking about the trader the
trader loves the volatility the trader
loves the the trader wants more noise
because he's not investing he's trading
or she's trading right when I say he I'm
yeah let's I'm talking about everybody
right right he she right but uh they
right they want that noise because
they're a Trader they're not an investor
so they're making money based on how the
stock moves is it you know it could be
within a two-minute time span could be
in a 10-minute time span could be in a
day but their focus is different from
the investor so they're trading off of
volatility they're trading off the
volatility they're trading off the noise
that's created today on the internet on
Twitter on LinkedIn on Facebook on
Google on Amazon they're trading all
that noise and now you know today what
exists which didn't exist then the smart
logic algorithms smart logic algorithms
are exactly that they scan and scrape
the headlines whether it's in the Wall
Street Journal The Washington Post the
New York Times or Bloomberg or on the or
on Twitter or on Facebook whatever
headline it can see and the smart logic
algorithms are written in such a way
that they react to words is the word
positive is the word negative is the
headline positive is the headline
negative and when it is then the
algorithm then assumes or makes a
decision that's a negative headline
negative for the market they initiate
sell orders at the same time they
withdraw the the the inline buy side
interest which creates a vacuum in
prices which is why you see the
volatility that you see well right but
doesn't mean as an investor you
shouldn't take advantage of that because
you should because most of the time that
volatility is short-term noise and in
that noise it creates opportunity
because it dislocates a stock
temporarily and if you're a long-term
investor and you were buying Coke at 50
and now it's trading at 46 because of
the noise damn I'll buy more at 46 I
loved it at 50 I damn well love it at 46
yeah right so what's interesting is how
much psychology still drives the market
because but now it's automated
psychology right if you're if you're
going out and grabbing headlines and
words and so on saying oh we're going to
trade based on headlines not based on
analytics you as the trader you've
pre-programmed your computer so you're
not really even doing it you've
pre-programmed your computer to respond
to how the algorithm reads the market so
if the if the market trades down your
your black box is going to generate Buy
and or sell loaders based on what's
happening in the market you're just
sitting there you're reading the paper
you're doing all the work I mean you
you're you're clearly going to oversee
it yes but you're not actually sitting
there every time it happens and type in
buy 100 shars of this sell 200 shars of
that you're not doing that the
computer's doing that well and that's
what's amazing to me because I would
have figured oh you know became somewhat
uh impartial when you got into
algorithmic trading right but it's
looking for certain words that carry
certain emotions that's correct now
listen and and that's the frustrating
part of it for a lot of people because
you and I can have that same headline
and you and I could talk about it okay
it's a ridiculous headline right but we
understand that because we can interpret
the headline and have a conversation and
not react the algorithm can't can't
interpret that all the algorithm knows
is that word's negative or that headline
is negative meanwhile it really isn't
right it it might feel like it is but it
isn't but the algorithm reacts the
market ey takes off so for instance
here's a perfect example back in the
middle of the crisis in 2010 when the
when when Global markets were just
getting they were continue they were
crushed they were up they were down this
one day remember when the European Banks
were getting just crushed and so every
week there was a meeting in Brussels
amongst the European Union and 27 member
countries getting together trying to
figure out what to do and Germany and
Angela Merkel was at the head of the
table because Germany was Germany right
was kind of in control of the place and
I'll never forget it and this is just
one of so many stories like this but you
know it was all about the meeting in
Brussels and and and and and and
everyone's hanging on every word that's
going to happen and Angela Merkel stands
up and leaves the room and so the
Twitter lights up Merkel just left the
room okay is that positive or is that
negative I'm not really sure is that a
negative headline or is that a positive
it was viewed as a negative headline
because Angela Merkel is Germany
representing Germany and she picks up
and leaves the room so the market sells
off the poor woman had to go to the
bathroom I just about say maybe she had
to go to that's all she had to do 5
minutes later she comes walking back in
and the Twitter headline says Merkel
enters the room and then the bucket
takes off again that's but you see how
ridiculous that is I was going to make
that as a joke no but that is the truth
the the funny part about it is it would
be a joke yeah but it's not a joke
because because the Twitter things like
Twitter and Linkedin and Facebook have
created all this noise that creates his
volatility and so angler Mel does leave
the room wow okay but that's Twitter
viewed that as a negative because we're
in the middle of these negotiations and
then she comes back in the room so they
go wow she's back everything's great and
so you know the market sells off and the
market rallies and part of that is what
honestly is what annoys the investing
public because they don't understand the
volatility in the market like why does
the market do that and so therefore it
gives the
impression that the market is more of a
casino than a place to invest right
that's the wrong message and this is
where I get so worked up about the way
the industry and the SEC has allowed
that to evolve but listen there's a lot
of pressure from the tech industry
clearly because they stand to benefit
right right and so you know oh it's a
21st century you have to be modern okay
great so so what I spend my time trying
to do is I try to make people understand
that it it is not really a Casino if
you're a long-term investor there's huge
opportunity to invest in the market huge
there are plenty of great companies out
there that you would do very well by
creating a portfolio you as an investor
just have to learn to eliminate the
noise yeah and that's I think the most
that that's the hardest part and it's
especially the hardest part for people
people that are maybe our generation
that understand what it used to be like
Millennials say they don't know any
different that's just what it is so to
them it's normal it's not normal so if
if I'm somebody who say Okay I want to
be an investor in the market I've got
401K I've got IRAs I've got whatever
I've got yeah am I smarter to buy
indexes to bet on individual companies
yeah what do you advice people well so
it depends on your personality depends
on your profile meaning your risk
profile are you you tend to be a type A
or type B personality uh you know ETFs
and mutual funds is much more passive
investing which are fine they they do
that does very well and it also relieves
you of the of the sense that you always
have to be you always have to be
checking your phone or looking at where
the stock is trading because I bought it
at 50 oh my God it's trading at 49 and
you make yourself crazy right right and
an ETF it's less so and it's passive
investing ETF means what exchange traded
fund an exchange traded fund is like a
mutual fund except it trades like a
stock so you can buy it and sell it
intraday mutual fund you buy it you get
the price at the end of the day so if
you put an order in a mutual buy a
mutual fund today you're going to get
the closing price tonight if you put an
order in to sell the mutual fund today
you're going to get the closing price
tonight and an ETF like you know a
technology ETF so it's a mutual fund
that's made up of all these different
technology stocks that trades like a
stock that you can buy and sell all day
long that moves like a stock and you can
buy it and sell it all day long and so
that that's a form of passive investing
it kind of you know lit up uh in the
late 90s um started with the S&P right
the S&P 500 uh and now you can buy an
ETF I I can't even imagine I bet you
there's more than 5,000 ETFs out there
that you can trade anything under the
sun any country any combination because
they're all very inventive right um in
terms of exposure that you can get and a
lot of those ETFs are not meant for joq
public the average investor things like
a technology ETF or financials or the
consumer discretionary those are great
MH but you know they've got they've also
got ETFs that are really designed for
the for the Traders and for the big
hedge funds that are managing risk and
so you know you can get ETFs that are
levered two and three times which really
means you know if if the Market's up a
100 and you buy an ETF that's levered
three times you're going to be up 300
right conversely if the Market's down
100 you're going to be down 300 right
and so those aren't meant for the
individual investor and I would never
suggest that any just or go anywhere
near them but the problem is everybody
plays in the same sandbox and so
everybody gets dragged down or they get
dragged up and so you have to be able to
understand that as well so depending on
your level of of uh of risk uh and what
you can stand and where you are in your
life are you 30 are you 60 that's going
to make a difference as well and you're
getting to my next question is say okay
so I'm realizing like you're saying you
know there's different uh approaches for
different types of people right so it's
not it's not just this kind of dactic
thing you got to know the the human what
are the most important questions to ask
yourself well what's your risk profile
what's your tolerance level where are
you in your life what do you have to
provide for do you have 10 kids at home
that you're trying to provide for do you
have no kids at home is it just you and
your wife do you want to retire at 40 do
you want to retire at 70 and so there's
a lot of question and most of it though
revolves around risk really what's your
risk tolerance level what's your wife's
risk to your partner's risk tolerance
level because you're in this together
I think one of the most important things
and I wish somebody really had had this
conversation with me when I was their
age is that especially if you partner up
with somebody you know and this becomes
your life partner is that both of you
have to be on the same page you have to
be you can't have one person you know
that's way out here in the wrist
spectrum and the other one that's way
over here in the wrist spectrum because
then you're going to have a hard time
trying to come to the middle doesn't
mean you can't have those opinions but
you have to find a way to come to the
middle so that everybody feels you know
compromised and everybody feels like
they got a little protection on this
side they a little protection on that
side but I think those are the questions
as an investor M that you want to ask
and so you want to you want to lay out
your time frame you want to put together
a if you're an active investor meaning
you want to buy individual stocks then
you got a lot of homework to do because
there's a lot of stocks out there so
you're got to do all your homework to
figure out what are the right stocks
what fits my profile what do I like am I
more conservative am I more risky do I
want high growth do I want value do I
want some combination right does it make
sense to buy if you're if you're going
to do individual stocks does it make
sense to buy things that you are
interested in or care about cuz you're
likely to want to follow it of course of
course that was one of I think that was
Peter Lynch's Mantra you know what I
mean buy what you like yeah buy what you
understand like for instance I don't own
Facebook I would never own Facebook I
don't use Facebook and so therefore I
would never buy I don't care it's gone
up 500% I would never use Facebook so
therefore I would never buy Facebook I
just wouldn't right what kind of things
do you buy what do you like so I tend to
be a little bit more in the conservative
side and the value side right there is a
part of the portfolio that's got growth
in it for sure CU it needs to but I tend
to be more of the straight and narrow I
know you wouldn't necessarily tell that
by my personality but I tend to be more
of the straight and narrow and so you
know it's like the turtle in the the
turtle and and the the totus in the hair
right slow and steady wins the race yeah
you can you can run real fast but you're
G to get slammed the next day slow and
steady for me and I would and I would
advise for most people especially if
you're you know you're a doctor you're a
lawyer you're something else you're not
in this industry that slow and steady
wins the race and listen investing is
dynamic it's not static it's not like
you say okay I'm going to buy apple and
Johnson and Johnson and and GE and then
just let it sit there for the rest of my
life no you're G to buy those but when
they make certain outsize moves you
might trim a little bit and then buy
something else you still keep a core
position but you're not going to you're
not going to necessarily sell it all but
you're going to trim you're going to
take some of that cash and reinvest it
in a new opportunity and so it's very
dynamic and that's the other thing if
you're going to be an active investor
right if you're going to be a passive
investor it's still Dynamic MH um but
less so because you know you're going to
have you know you're going to have your
technology exposure through an ETF
you're going to have your consumer
durable exposure through an ETF you
might have international exposure and
then as the market as the market you
know as the market goes through its
Cycles again you're going to do the same
thing with DTF if technology stocks
really take off and the ETF is really
surged in value you might take a little
bit off the top and put it to work in
something else doesn't mean take it all
off it could but it doesn't necessarily
mean that that's what I mean about
investing is is dynamic you can't just
you can't just put it there and leave it
so you're at this point late 50s I guess
if I'm doing my math 58 58 okay say
it so let's say when you were 30 yeah
what were you doing then as far as
investing versus now at 58 so when I was
30 I was really just building right
because I was young we had listen
I I had gotten married at 25 we had I
had a child at 26 I bought a house and
so assets were being diverted to other
forms of investment house was an
investment for sure but you know I had I
didn't have a lot of extra cash at the
time but the cash I did have I had in a
401k or an IRA and so therefore it was
it that's the way it was invested at
first because you know most of the money
I was making was going towards kind of
living my life right um but yet I
started to build a p like I said that
repres that reflected both me and my
wife right because my wife also grew up
in this industry and she worked on the
floor She certainly understood it she
understood supply and demand she
understood what the news meant she
understood what investing was right and
so um so we put a plan together it
tended to be a little bit more
conservative not way not way out in the
Spectrum it was all stocks when I was 30
it was no fixed income because I was way
too young right but they tended to be
more you know it was Proctor and Gamble
it was Disney it was Coca colola it was
all these things that that I know and I
love right stuff you know right and so
today then as you move along and you get
older and your life changes and you know
your kids grow up and then you
potentially have grandchildren and how
you g what are you going to do there and
what's the portfolio going to look like
so now that you're 58 so it takes on a
different tone right there's a little
bit more fixed income in there to add
some stability what do you mean by fixed
income bonds okay to add some stability
there's and and see now at my age now
there's going to be more um especially
in the environment that we're in with
rates being almost negative you want
stocks that have great dividend yields
right because you're going to get income
from that but they're also going to be
stocks that you're going to hold again
you know some of the big Americana names
right it's listen I I from that point of
view I'm really boring I mean maybe
that'll look boring but from that point
of view because I tend to be I tend to
be a little bit more conservative
because listen I'm 58 right so I hear
people uh that are critical some gurus
of 401ks like saying you that's a you
know there's so many fees etc etc you're
deferring tax but you're going to have
to pay you know and maybe taxes are
going to be higher what are your
thoughts on it well ta taxes going be
high but the whole point of the 401K and
the IRA is that you don't take that
money out until you're older when when
your income bracket is going to be lower
so you T I mean that was really the way
it was designed right so when you took
the money out in an IRA if you put the
money in pre-tax yeah then when you take
it out it's you have to pay tax on it in
a Roth IRA it's different because you
pay the tax then you put the money in
and then you pay no tax at the end right
but the Roth is relatively new compared
to the IRA sure sure but that is the
difference right I wouldn't necessarily
listen I think any of the savings
Vehicles 401ks SE plans IRAs uh Roth
IRAs I think they're all tremendous
plans for Americans to take care of
themselves because who knows what's
going to happen to Social Security and
listen if you're depending on your
$2,000 a month to live on Social
Security you better you better think
about working till you die right because
that ain't happening and so all those
saving plans in my mind are great and
and the government encourages you to do
it and you get a benefit for doing it so
you should be doing it and whether or
not you're 30 years old whether or not
you'd start by putting $100 a month away
whatever it is just put it away you'd be
very surprised 30 years later what
happens and then you know is you become
a little bit more successful the 100
turns into 200 the 200 turns into 500
the 500 turns into a
thousand and it and it ends up
compounding and adding up fairly quickly
I mean
fairly quickly it's 30 years out but
when you run the model and you see what
that's going to look like okay so you're
30 and then you figure out if I put $500
a month away for the next 30 Years and I
earn 7% all of a sudden that $500 a
month is going to be a million bucks
whatever the number is right I'm just
right there's a
calculation you can do it on Quicken you
know you go all these different places
you know it'll give you the what the
expectation is depending on the
parameters you put in right so no I
don't I think all the savings Vehicles
retirement S I think they're tremendous
what are most of your activities today
now uh you know you've got all this
experience behind you you've seen the
transition from the old days to the new
days Etc what do you do now so after 38
years I finally uh I finally left the
New York Stock Exchange because listen I
had a tremendous career there it was I
wouldn't I wouldn't have changed that
for anything in my life probably first
of all because I met my wife there yeah
and then I got married now I have two
beautiful children you know had I not
been there I would never have met or who
knows what my life would have been but
one way the other and I lived through
the turn of the century I lived through
kind of all the automation I lived
through the exchang is going public I
lived through the crash of you know 2007
8 9 10 11
12 and uh and then I finally in January
of this year decided that it was it was
now time for chapter two in my life that
you know the the business that I had on
the floor what didn't exist anymore
because the
technology really really did away with
it and what recognized ultimately was
that it wasn't fun for me anymore not
that the industry is not fun and not
that being at the New York Stock change
wasn't fun it wasn't that at all it was
just that the automation is such now
that you go to your desk you don't talk
to anybody because the phone doesn't
ring anymore because everyone sends you
orderflow comes electronically and they
send you instant messages because that's
all the Millennials how to do nobody
wants to talk I want to talk to somebody
but nobody wants to talk right they all
want to send Bloomberg messages and
instant messages I not me you know the
25 year olds or the 30-y olds great go
at it at least in this business to be
able to relay that action in the stock
and be able to make decisions and
strategize and be able to be creative
with the client that's what made it so
exciting and interesting because again
everyone's got a listen you could have a
client that's like a type B very you
know typy personality and then you're
trying to get him to understand what's
going on in the stock and why he needs
to be more excited why need such a you
know and so it took finesse it took the
ability to be able to sell that story
and if you really want to buy this stock
because listen a mutual fund's going to
buy Boeing they're not going to buy it
and sell it in 10 minutes they're buying
it because four years from now they say
it's going to go up 70% then they want
to sell it up
70% they're not buying it to sell it
right away and so you had to be able to
tell that story why you should be a
little bit more aggressive or less
aggressive depending on what was
happening and so it was all very
strategic you picked up the pH and you
talk to somebody again today they don't
do that just because it's all automated
so what are you doing now well I live in
Florida and I joined a wealth I took all
this all this experience which makes
perfect sense and joined a wealth
management firm as a senior market
strategist uh and adviser and it makes
perfect sense for me because it fits my
personality uh it takes all my
experience both institutional and brings
it kind of to the retail level and
allows me to have these conversations um
with you know High net worth and alter
High net worth individuals and so it
makes perfect sense for me and I didn't
you know once I left once I left the New
York Stock Exchange there was no reason
any longer to have to live in New York
my kids are grown right and so there was
no reason to have to live in New York
and the truth is the weather's nicer in
Florida and it shows by your T oh thank
you so now you know we've got people who
are trying to sort through all this and
I know a lot of times um you know second
nature terms to you are uh you not are
maybe mistifying to other people like
you talk about you know retail you know
versus you know institutions or you talk
about uh I heard you earlier talk about
market makers so so maybe let's let's
talk about maybe a few of the terms that
people should understand so they can
navigate this landscape a little bit so
what's retail versus in so so retail
think about retail as you as an
individual you your wife your parents
your brothers your sister whatever the
retail is the individual institutions
are asset managers mutual funds are
institutions hedge funds are
institutions what's a hedge fund okay so
a hedge fund is a is a is a is an asset
manager that pulls the assets of indiv
of investors and they bring the money
together so instead of you instead of
you singly you come into this hedge fund
and you know 10 guys give give him you
know a million dollars a piece other
guy's got 10 million bucks and he levers
that three or four times and now he's
got 40 million bucks and then he and
then he'll trade the market he'll invest
on your behalf so you participate
everything everything he does right good
and or bad but a hedge fund unlike a
mutual fund um is a riskier investment
so therefore the requirements to get in
are are are different because you have
to have you have to have kind of the
capital and the wherewithal and the
experience to really right and that's
all good are they a newer phenomenon no
because it seems like they're talked
about a lot more now than they used to
be they exploded kind of in the late 80s
MH mid the late 80s hedge funds because
the market was just out on fire and so
it created lot of opportunity for people
to trade so they exploded that I I I
think they're talking about them now
because there have some there have been
some real big hedge fund blowups I
meaning you know some of these guys have
made wrong bets and they've had their
heads handed to them and so that makes
the news a mutual fund like a hedge fund
is an asset manager but they're much
more conservative you know Fidelity is a
mutual fund company I mean you could s
just pick up the Wall Street Journal
there there's a thousand mutual fund
companies but they also pull the money
of in of individual investors retail
investors and so they get a bigger pool
of capital to invest so they go out and
they buy a million shares of IBM and if
you were singly trying to buy I you're
going and buy 200 shares of IBM and so
therefore there's there's just more bang
for your buck if you're involved in a
pool of money right the retail is just
you doing it on your own right right uh
and the institution is the institution
what do you think the future holds now
so you you you've seen all the changes
you you you've seen old school new
contemporary market now where's it going
so let start with the exchange the
exchanges continue to
evolve uh part of it like like most
things that technology does is it forces
you to evolve um and so the exchange has
continued to evolve it's very 21st
century it's very very Hightech um and
it will continue to evolve based on
where technology drives it right and I
think at some point the technolog is
going to get so
sophisticated um that uh the trading
will take place immediately like today
when I buy stock or sell stock there's
still there's still the one day
clearance and so you know I buy it I
don't get it till tomorrow I think in
the future it's going to if I buy it I'm
going to buy like I'm gonna have it
right now I'm gonna buy it from you and
it's goingon to be in my account right
now you're gonna have the money right
now and I'm gonna have the stock right
now but from an investing
perspective I don't think much changes
in the sense that investing is still
investing you want to buy stock you're
going to buy stock you're going to
create a portfolio you're going to
generate wealth for a lifetime you have
to build a portfolio whether you build
it by thinking about I want to buy 500
shares of coke and you're going to think
it and all of a sudden it's going to be
in your account right if Google has
their way I'm going to have these
glasses on my head and I'm going to
think about it all of a sudden it's
going to trade right um but investing is
investing and so the investing game will
never change it it might get more
complicated more complex but see that in
and of itself creates in my view creates
issues because as the products that
you create become more complex then the
system becomes more risky and so so the
perfect example of that is the crash of
2007 the great financial crisis 2007
2008 because a lot of the a lot of the
products that had been created that were
not Equity products and they were all
three-letter acronyms abss cdss CMOS all
these derivative products that were
traded against stocks and against the
mortgage market and against housing
prices and all that stuff were very
complex and and the retail public wasn't
going out and buying those products they
were all very
institutional but what happened you know
they were all designed oh and this is
how it's going to work and in a perfect
environment this is how they're going to
work and when the environment was
perfect and everything traded fine
everyone's patting themselves on the
back say look at how great I am until it
didn't and when the economy started to
collapse in 2007 not only the us but the
global economy started to come under
pressure um and then we all know what
happened it got worse and it got worse
and then what happened happened is those
complex derivative products that were
all built and designed and they worked
so efficiently and look this how was
going to happen they didn't work so well
and in a down environment or in or in a
difficult economic environment the whole
thing blew up and so what happened what
what really happened during that crisis
and people are so quick to blame Wall
Street Wall Street Wall Street but when
they blame Wall Street like they're
pointing their finger at the New York
Stock Exchange that's not W that's not
the Wall Street that created all these
product they were the big investment
Banks they were all these other all
these other people that work in the
industry that created these products but
what end up happening when the economy
started to
stumble some of these products became IL
liquid right they became difficult to
trade and then as and then as the
economy got worse they became even more
difficult to trade and nobody you tried
to sell it there's no buyer right and so
then what do you do you start to panic
because now you you can't sell it but
you want to sell it because you think
it's going lower but there's no one that
wants to buy it so what do you do you
sell what you can and so you hit the
button to sell GE or Coke or rabbit
because you know why because you can
because the public markets are the
public markets there's always a bid
there's always an offer you may not like
the bid and offer but could you sell it
you absolutely could there's no there
were no bids and offers in those complex
derivative products and so everybody
around the world by the way that own
these products cuz that's what they all
did they all they all sold it to each
other it was a big it was a big Ponzi
scheme my opinion but it all collapsed
and so institutions that owned all that
crap around the world could no longer
sell it and so then the world started to
panic and people started I want my money
you know investors who were in those I
want my money I want calling up the
broker I want my money I want my money
it's like the old run on the bank it's
all the run on the bank and so what
happened was they sold what they could
versus selling what they should have but
they couldn't sell that because there
were no buyers so they sold Coke and
Abbott Johnson and IBM and and they did
it and they did it and they did it for a
year and the market went down 60% wow
60% and so anyone that you know worked
their whole life that maybe had two
three four5 million dos in their Ira
lost 60% of its value by the time we hit
rock bottom W right and so the problem
with a lot of those complex products and
my my view on the future is we need to
be very careful and the SEC needs to be
very careful on what they really
allow to be designed and developed
because remember I just said it we all
play in the same sandbox just like in
the crisis of 2007 and8 we were all
playing that sandbox I didn't own any of
that crap I didn't own cdss and CMOS and
abss but still followed you into of
course it did and it followed you and it
followed him and it followed her and it
followed him followed everybody and so
therefore everybody got dragged down
right and so and so in retrospect
someone will say but look at the
opportunity created because then stocks
you know the market was down 60% yeah
okay unless you were one of the guys
that jumped out the window or or or or
or killed yourself because you lost your
life savings and remember I'm not making
that up they were people who did that
right remember and so therefore what I'm
concerned about about the future is the
level of complexity that the industry
allows to be traded in the public
markets so there's so basically it's a
full ecosystem in other words you can't
just say well I'm in stock right I'm not
in that other CRA correct but the people
you know when people are in that or the
institutions are in this other stuff it
still follows you back to your
investment that's right because it's all
in the same sandbox it's all in the same
now abss and cdos those are all fixed
income products so they weren't in the
equity sandbox but they were in the
bigger sandbox of financial services and
even though I had no exposure to those
Equity those fixed income products I got
slammed in the equity market and you did
and he did and she did yeah because they
panicked in that world they couldn't
sell them because there were no bids and
so they sold what they could MH you're
not going to sell Bank of Hawaii who
wants to buy Bank of Hawaii you're going
to sell GE and Johnson and Abbot but the
reality I guess was that GE was not
really worth less from a technical
standpoint it was the psychological
standpoint or I want get cash exactly
right so on the flip side of that I
guess if if you went in and bought it
okay but but the problem was your
exactly right right but GE goes from 30
to 25 you go oh my God it's down five
bucks it's a buy but then it goes to 20
and then it goes to 12 where's the
bottom so then you start to say I just
bought it at 30 I bought it at 25 I
bought it at 20 and now was trading at
12 then you start to panic because now
you throw it's the end of the world
right right if you ended up waiting and
you bought it all at six we're we it
traded down to you're a superstar but
who did that yeah what you said was
something that was really a worry at the
time is that it was the end of the world
I mean the whole thing thing could just
collapse well the truth is the financial
the Global Financial system came to the
brink and I don't think many people
really appreciate how close we came I
don't really think that they really
understood how close we came and the
issues with AIG and Goldman Sachs and
all these reinsurers how they were all
in bed with each other with these
products and what that really meant and
so in the end Ben banki and Timmy gner
the ECB
the right the European Central Bank the
IMF the bank of Japan uh The People's
Bank of China you know all these central
banks around the
world did what they had to do because we
were on the brink of Armageddon was it
us AR it was Global Armageddon and so
those Banks did what they had to do and
people were very critical but the people
that were very
critical didn't really understand how
close to the edge we were
and so what I'm fearful of because I I
think history repeats itself and that's
the problem and you know in 20 years
there's not going to be anyone in a
position at the treasury or the SEC that
has any recollection of what happened in
2007 and so my fear is that that we're
not going to learn and that we're not
going to put uh uh rule sets in place
that say no you can't do this mhm I
don't care what you say you can't do it
right and I don't think that's going to
happen because I think the banks the big
investment banks have too much power I
think they get down there and they just
and they you know and and they have too
much power and because they create these
products and you know part of it was the
products were unregulated and I would go
back to Alan Greenspan on that because
alen Greenspan said no they don't need
to be regulated well that's
baloney because they were unregulated
which is part of the problem right so if
you want to create the complex products
and then regulate them so
heavily maybe I go why go there why go
there so then maybe to sum this all up
yeah as you're looking back uh through
these experiences you know you see how
you know things really bad things happen
people get wiped out what have you yeah
but at this point you still think that
the market is a good investment for
people to go into the buy equities and
and to uh invest here I I I think as a
long again I qualified by saying as a
long-term investor if you're somebody
who's 25 or 30 years old and you're just
starting absolutely you should be in the
market how you design it is going to be
up to you if you're someone who's a big
risk taker well then go for it but then
understand the risk but absolutely you
should go into the market absolutely I I
would still I'm still a buyer of the US
capital system I'm still a buyer of the
opportunity that investing creates to
generate wealth not only for you and
your partner your wife whatever and your
children and your grandchildren
potentially that it that it provides and
so I'm absolutely a buyer of America and
I'm a buyer of of the investing process
for sure I guess I could easily say
you've seen it
all yeah and uh yeah so you have this
really great historic and contemporary
perspective on the markets and and the
experience of the markets and what they
mean to Everyday people in the world so
I I appreciate you taking a time sitting
down sharing all of it I don't think you
held back
no so I appreciate you coming here
showing up not holding back and sharing
it all you're very welcome it's my
pleasure I really hope you're enjoying
the free viewing of the wealth
breakthroughs series and for those of
you who already jumped in and purchased
the series I want to give you a sincere
thank you this supports our work
supports the mission we have and getting
this information throughout the world
people need to understand wealth they
need to have their own wealth
breakthrough and you buying the series
helps us get everybody this information
so thank you so much for jumping in and
doing exactly
[Music]
that okay by now you know I wasn't
kidding when I said Kenny is larger than
life the man is Wall Street and his own
Journey with wealth breakthroughs took
him from college grad making a few
hundred bucks a week to master of the
markets now let's switch over to Carl
Allen if you've ever wondered what an
earthquake everything changes after this
wealth breakthrough really looks like
listen to Carl's story and take notes
then watch his interview again and take
more notes Carl's one of the most
amazing intelligent and humble wealth
Geniuses we talked to filming this
entire series his story is heartfelt
inspiring and could unlock your path to
the wealth breakthrough your seek
speaking here's Jeff Hayes with Carl's
story so Carl thank you so much for
being here thank you very much I'm
looking forward to this because this is
a topic that I'm fascinated by and
excited to learn about so why don't you
tell us a little bit about who you are
and what you do and how you got here
okay so my name is KL Allen I'm
originally from Manchester England I now
spend about half my time in the states
and half my time here kind of basically
grew up as a Wall Street investment guy
so was buying and selling businesses for
lots of corporates like HP and IBM and
Microsoft GE and then about 10 years ago
my life changed I had a little baby not
me personally but my wife and I decided
to um become an entrepreneur and buy and
sell businesses for myself which uh I'm
still doing to this day but about four
years ago I started teaching and
coaching entrepreneurs how to basically
model my system which is buying a small
business from say 1 to five $5 million
in revenues and buying it without a
spending your own money to acquire that
business and B once you acquire it not
having to run that business day today if
you don't want to so those are the two
things that I do I'm still doing my own
deals inside of my private Equity Firm
that I run with a partner and that I'm
still coaching and training
entrepreneurs to basically follow my
system that I've been using most of my
career so I've been a lifetime
entrepreneur and have had some great
successes and some spectacular failures
and Vern Harish was saying a few weeks
ago his new mantra is the money is not
in startups it's in scale ups and
listening to ver and when I found out
about you I'm like okay
this buying a business I I look at the
ideas I had that I thought were
brilliant that lost mine and my investor
money the risk is is
on the takeoff much more than so I'm
eager to hear so let's do a a a high
level View and then we'll dig deeper
into it if somebody's interested in
buying a business and doesn't have a lot
of capital what do they need to start
with yeah so the first advice I would
give to anybody that wants to get into
business is don't start a business
actually buy one that someone else has
built and no longer wants to own last
year over six million Americans started
a company from scratch and 96% of those
will fail within a 10-year period and
50% of them will fail inside of one year
and those statistics are from Michael
Gerber who's the author of the emth one
of the one of my favorite alltime
business books and he's worked with
hundreds and hundreds of thousands of
businesses so and my kind of analogy
with this is like Tesla so if you want
to buy a Tesla Dua go and buy the wheels
buy the glass buy the chasset buy the
giant iPad buy the tires and put it all
on your driveway and figure out you know
how do I build it all or do you go to
the dealership buy one that they've
built and then Finance the purchase of
that car through Tesla where you're
paying for that car month on month and
it's the exact same thing buying a
business so rather than start a business
go and buy one that somebody else has
built and no longer wants to own there's
over 2.4 million of them for sale today
in the United States only one in 12 one
in 13 are actually going to sell in the
next 12 months lots of baby boomers
10,000 a day looking to retire big
percentage of those own a small business
so if you're an entrepreneur and you
want to become a business owner go and
buy a business that someone else has
built and doesn't want to own anymore
and provided it's a good match to your
skills and what you want to do you can
acquire that business and get somebody
else to finance that deal using other
people's money so you're talking about
in the 1 to 5 million range what example
businesses are we talking about is this
like a dry cleaners or what are we
talking so no we're looking more kind of
you know one there's not many dry
cleaners that are doing a million
dollars a year as a standalone you could
buy 20 of them and kind of roll them up
into a group but we're looking at more
kind of established developed businesses
so in the engineering in the
manufacturing sector anything in techn
ology or software anything in
Professional Services so PR firms
recruitment consultancies you know web
design marketing agencies those types of
businesses and you can also do deals
although I personally don't like do
doing deals in retail or buying hotels
or restaurants that the kind of Leverage
buyout model that we utilize very very
old 64 year old Wall Street tool still
been used today that's how we're doing
these deals but you can pretty much do
deals in any particular sector the one
to five million range or you could maybe
go as high as 10 those two boundaries
are are quite important anything below a
million then really or kind of maybe
half a million at a stretch you're not
really buying a business you're buying
somebody that has a job inside of their
own business so when they leave they
take all the Goodwill and all the kind
of mechanics of how the business works
so those deals are not very good deals
to do when you go above 5 million in
revenues and even kind of Maximum 10
million there's a lot more competition
for those types of businesses you have
private Equity firms and you have a lot
of trade competitors that would buy a
business at that scale so a kind of 1 to
five million Market that's really our
sweet spot where we're finding lots of
really good high quality deals and where
do you find these businesses yeah so
there's lots of proprietary methods that
I've developed over the past 26 27 years
I've been doing this so we go to
business brokers like everybody else but
we'll only typically work with a deal
where it's been listed with a broker say
at least 9 months because Mrs Brokers
most of them they're not very good some
of them are okay but they're in the
market really to sell a business to
another business they're not interested
in selling those businesses to people
like ourselves because they promise
quite crazy valuations with Sellers and
we're obviously coming in and we're
looking to do more sensible you know
creative deals apart from business
brokers most of our deals come through
our Network so building our network of
both deal intermediaries like CPA and
lawyers and wealth managers and
accountants but also a lot of the people
that we know in industry and anybody can
do it you can build your own network
whether it's on LinkedIn or going to
events or other types of of networking
activity and if you're a small business
owner and you've decided the times come
maybe to sell the business only 20% of
sellers ever go to a business broker
because it's very expensive and takes a
lot of time most people they call their
own network they'll call their wealth
manager because the wealth manager is
going to be then investing the money if
they sell they'll call their lawyer or
their attorney they'll call their CPA
because those are the individuals that
are going to help them get that deal to
Market and get it closed to somebody
else so if you're an entrepreneur
looking to buy a small business and
you're networking with those types of
individuals it's a great way to get some
very high quality deal flow and it's
what we call off-market which means that
it's not published on a website
somewhere where hundreds and thousands
of people can see it it's a one onone
kind of situation and what's great about
that is that like anything in life you
know businesses are bought and sold
between people so a massive part of our
system and how we teach it is a lot
about the psychology of the seller and
the psychology of how they think and
what they're looking for when they sell
their business and the interesting thing
is it's not always about money it's
about other things so let's talk about
financing for a minute it's like the the
because that in your Tesla example you
know I don't want the car assembled in
the driveway much rather buy it at the
dealership but if they didn't have a
financing mechanism for me then suddenly
I'm not in the market y for a Tesla y so
how do you help people Finance
businesses so so there's four countries
in the world that have got very very
majure financing markets for buying
businesses so obviously the USA it's by
far the biggest the UK is next and then
you have Canada and Australia there are
other parts of the world that do these
types of deals but if you went to say
South America or India or China it's
very very hard to get that type of
financing but in the Western World you
know there's trillions of dollars
available to put into deals so when
we're looking to buy these businesses
we're typically using three types of
financing the first one that we always
try and use in in a deal is seller
financing so it's like buying the
business like leasing to buy it so
you're not raising any money from the
financial markets so let's say you owned
a business and it was doing a million
dollar a year in revenues and it was
making $100,000 a year in profit and I
was buying that business for say a three
times multiple of profit which is about
the average maybe a bit less so that
300,000 I could say to you I will buy
that business from you and I will pay
you for that business over say 5 years
so you don't have to come into work
anymore I will take over your business
and run your business and grow it but
you still get paid month on month as if
you were coming into work and for a lot
of Baby Boomers and a lot of retiring
entrepreneurs or or other business
owners that's still quite an attractive
proposition that somebody's taking over
their business dealing with all the
problems that that business has on a
daily basis but as the owner the old
owner they can stay in bed or go play
golf or go on vacation and still make
the money that they've been used to
making because a lot of business owners
stay in their businesses far too long a
because they can't sell them and B they
still want the income from that business
to be able to live their lives the
second thing that we do is apart from
the seller financing and sometimes it's
enough to be able to just pay the seller
from the future profits of the business
in my private Equity Firm we're buying a
coach company up in the northern
elements of Scotland fantastic deal
we're raising no financing from the
outside Market we're just paying for
that business every month over five
years and the seller is more than happy
to do that deal if that seller wanted a
say a closing payment then we would be
looking at using the Assets in the
business all the cash flows in the
business to be able to introduce some
financing from an external provider so
it could be an asset-based lender it
could be an angel investor or it could
be the SBA uh what you have in the
United States which is phenomenal we
don't have it in the UK or anywhere else
is you've got something called the SBA
7A Loan program which is rocket fuel for
entrepreneurs buying businesses the SBA
will lend you 90% up to 90% of the
purchase price of a business up to $5
million you just have to come up with
the 10% deposit which if you've got the
cash you can put that in if the business
has got Surplus cash inside of it you
can use some of that or you can partner
with an angel investor that will put
that little bit of that 10% in and allow
you to buy that business really without
using your own money which is kind of
the Mantra that we're doing inside of
our business so how hard is it to
qualify for one of these SBA so SBA you
need a credit rating I believe of around
690 we're actually doing an SBA deal
right now inside of our private Equity
Firm we're buying a phenomenal
e-learning business in Texas which is
going to be a phenomenal deal and then
we're going to roll that up into a much
larger opportunity so to qualify for SBA
you need to have some knowledge and
understanding of the market which I
believe is very very important for any
entrepreneur buying a business if you've
spent your life or you've spent 10 years
working say in web design then go and
buy a web design company or an IT
services company you know don't go and
buy a restaurant or a hotel or a
laundromat buy something that's that's
kind of in your lane so the SBA want to
see that you've got some industry
experience um you have to have
reasonably good credit if you want to
apply for an SBA loan and that's the
only time when you're doing a deal where
your own individual credit as the buyer
actually comes under scrutiny when
you're using other types of financing so
you're financing the balance sheet or
you're using other types of investment
then really the financier is more
concerned about the credit of the
business that's being funded not the
credit of the individual that's going to
be coming in to become the business
owner but the SBA is is Rocket Fuel it
is a complex process it does take a lot
longer by doing SBA but they give you a
a huge chunk of money to be able to put
down on that deal and like with any
seller the more money you can pay them
at closing the smaller the total amount
of the deals going to be just because of
the time you know value of money so it's
very important yeah it seemed to be a
strong negotiating point to to be able
to offer that what's the length you say
it's a lengthy process what is lengthy
in this case so if we hadn't had the
government shut down quite recently
because um the SBA is a government it's
a federal government agency the small
business administration when uh when the
president shut down the government
however many months ago uh there was a
huge backlog so I think our deal is
probably going to take start to finish
around three months from the provider
that we've definitely decided to go with
um so it's generally about a three-month
process if you're financing a deal
through traditional methods you're just
calling a bank and looking to borrow
against receivables or real estate or
inventory or or fixed assets inside of
the balance sheet of the business then
typically it's a lot faster 30 to 45
days normally uh but generally start to
finish when you're buying a business
you're looking at 90 to 100 days you
know before you you know you start
searching you find a business you start
having meetings you do your due
diligence uh you apply for the financing
and then the lawyers come in and the CPA
and do the due diligence for you which
is making sure that the business uh does
what it says on the tin start to finish
about 9200 days if you're doing it
part-time if you were hitting it
full-time it was the only thing that you
you were doing in your career you can do
it a little bit faster generally around
45 to 50 days so you said something
really compelling to me at the very
beginning that you you look for
businesses to buy that are good
businesses but that you don't have to
run yes and you know that's a very attra
you know you know when you're talking
about somebody often business owners are
working in their business and these are
businesses that are large enough that
there's some infrastructure how do you
acquire a business but not end up
acquiring a job yeah so there's two
elements to that I think first of all
you still really have to have some
knowledge and understanding of an
industry that you're looking to acquire
in as an owner investor versus an owner
manager there's no harm there's there's
you know there's no reason why you can't
buy a business and go in and run it you
know there's thousands of students that
were coaching inside of our programs and
about a third of those they actually
want to go and buy a business and they
want to go in and they want to run it 9
to5 or or day to day that's fine if you
only want to buy one business if you
want to build a portfolio of businesses
then you can't multiply and scale
yourself you have to become more of an
owner investor so you still need to know
the sector because it's really important
to build raor and trust and credibility
with the seller of the business and also
with any external financiers if your
deal needs that financing so knowing the
Space is really still quite important
but then once you are going through that
acquisition process then really you're
looking for a GM you're looking for a
number two that can effectively run that
business dayto day for you and that
could be someone that you can promote
internally from within the business the
e-learning company that I'm uh acquiring
inside of my PE fund with my partner in
Texas that has a phenomenal number two a
general manager he's been there over
over 20 years since just after the
company was founded we're going to make
him the CEO and he's going to be like a
a small profit interest partner for us
inside of that deal to having somebody
like that or if there isn't anyone
inside of that business then you can use
your network which I mentioned earlier
having a Network's really important for
doing these types of deals then you can
bring somebody in to that deal to be
your your general manager and what's
great is because you're buying the
business without using your own money so
you're buying buying the shares in the
business essentially for free you can
gift a small percentage of the ownership
to that GM which then effectively means
they're incentivized and they're really
vested in helping you grow that business
and then if you don't know anybody in
your network that you can bring in and
there's nobody inside of the business
then you know you can use a recruitment
consultancy or use LinkedIn or do other
online methods to find the ideal partner
and what's great about having a partner
in a deal is not only are they there as
your kind of wingman to run that
business for you once you've acquired it
they can also help you do that deal as
well there's a couple of uh people
inside of our programs that we met
recently at one of our events and one
was a phenomenal marketer that had a
passion for doing engineering deals but
knew nothing about the sector he met
somebody at that event who uh didn't
really want to go through the work of
closing the deal but really we had the
gray hair really knew that space so
those guys have partnered and they've
closed one deal I think almost now maybe
two and they've got three other deals
that they're doing so that's another way
that you can kind of partner with people
one can do the deal one can run the
business for you and then scale that up
and kind of combine all of your
experiences and all of your efforts so I
knew you were training people I didn't
know you were doing events and that's
you know a couple of things you've said
the old line you're your network is your
net worth and this is where when people
come to me and go you know and want to
do something I always look around it
it's the part of the iceberg that's
under the water is the relationships
that you made so I love it that you're
doing events or you bringing a bunch of
your students together at the same time
and and um it's a beautiful place to
build a network yeah it is and obviously
we have different levels and tiers
inside of our various programs but um
our Academy members and our partner
members that we work with we we
typically get them all together uh the
last one that we did was was in London
there's about 50 people there uh we did
one in San Diego quite recently there's
about 30 people there and we're not only
coaching them in the room with lots of
new Advanced things that we're doing one
of the things that we also do which is
you know really makes my heart sing is
when I work back on Wall Street and in
corporate life and I was doing deals
whenever you closed a big deal they used
to give you it's called a tombstone
which is like a really weird thing cuz
that sounds like death but you get like
a crystal cut Tombstone with your name
and the date and you know the terms of
the deal that was done so we've started
doing that with some of our students uh
and these are ordinary people that you
know were stuck in a corporate 9 to5 or
have been laid off and you know just
wanted more money and freedom and and
kind of pride in becoming a business
owner we get all those people to our
events that have gone through our
programs and we hand them their deal
tombstones live in front of the rest of
the audience and there's kind of two
reasons that we do that you know one is
we want to celebrate with our successful
students that have implemented and have
got the results that they wanted to do
by following our programs but we also do
it as a big kind of incentive for the
people in the room that haven't done a
deal because people can look at me and
think well obviously Carl knows how to
do deals he's been doing it for 27 years
but when they can look at somebody um
like there's a a gentleman called Coston
who's now a very good friend of mine
came from Africa to the UK uh literally
only three years ago and when he got
here didn't even have enough money to
feed his family he since bought five
businesses leveraging our program his
son's got to private schools he travels
all over the place and they'll look at
him and think well he's like I was um 3
months ago you know if he can do it I
can do it so we use that you know for a
lot of kind of inspiration building for
the other members that we invite that
are kind of quite new or they've maybe
got a little bit stuck throughout their
Journey because they can see other
people taking action and doing their own
deals it's a massive incentive for them
to keep going so because you have
experience now training other people to
do it who have you discovered should not
do this is there a failure profile of
people that it's a really really good
question actually uh what I think
separates the the real winners from the
people that that just don't succeed and
you find this in any kind of coaching
scenario uh and it's saddens me that
100% of the people that subscribe to a
course or they come on to a training
program and they go to a seminar you
know 90% of those people will never
Implement anything that they learn and I
think that's crazy although personally
I've been to events I've bought things
I've done stuff and I've never
implemented them and the reason for that
is because I didn't have the leverage I
didn't have the purpose or the why or
the fuel to want to change my life in
that particular Instant by implementing
that program so what I would say is all
the people that have been really
successful they've had a burning desire
to want to get out of their current
situation and become a business owner it
could be that they they're stuck in a N9
to-5 and they hate their boss or they're
tired of not earning enough money or
they don't have a work life balance um
you know they're stuck in the office
every day missing their schools uh their
son's recital at schools and soccer
games and stuff so what I find when I
look at all the successful people that
have come through our programs they all
had real leverage to want to change and
go from being an employe to an employer
so I think to answer your question for
people that you know don't really have
that burning desire to want to buy a
business you know that's why they fail
yeah it's a really good point and it's
and for some people it can be an
intellectual exercise and if it gives
them pleasure then you know God bless
them I'm thinking of nightmare stories
of people um so I want to go back you
mentioned very quickly the due diligence
of having lawyers and accountants go in
can you highlight that a little bit for
yes so so if you look at the process of
buying a business it's it's like buying
a house you go you find one that you
like uh you build up a conversation with
the seller you make an offer maybe do a
little bit of arm wrestling and you
agree a price then like buying a house
you'd go and get a survey done you'd
make sure that there's no dry rot and no
one's going to build a highway through
the door or a nuclear power station at
the back of your yard it's the same with
buying a business but you don't want to
do it yourself you want to hire a CPA
and a lawyer to basically go through the
numbers and go through the legals and
make sure that that business is doing
exactly what it says that it's doing
that they've paid their taxes on time
that their financials are true and
accurate that their business model works
the way that they say it does that
there's no pending litigation they're
not being sued by anybody they don't
have any employee issues and that's what
CPAs and attorneys will do they'll go
through that business and make sure that
everything is Ticky Boo as we say in the
UK and if it's not what the seller has
to do when they're selling a businesses
they have to sign a warranty to
basically indemnify the buyer from
anything that that could go wrong with
the business that they haven't disclosed
as part of that due diligence so very
very important and what's great about
working with CPA and attorneys is in
most cases once you've found a deal and
you've got an agreed term sheet to buy
the business you've been to a financial
services company you've got a term sheet
for the financing that you need to do
the deal if the deal actually needs any
financing once all that's in place you
can package that up give it to a CPA and
to an attorney and in most cases they
will do the closing work for you to
paper the deal and you can pay them from
the business once you've closed it it's
called a contingent fee and it's how the
deal making World tends to work not just
at the massive kind of Wall Street level
where I basically learn my chops in this
business but also kind of in the small
one to5 million deal range that we're
really playing in now that's great so
what kind of businesses are you
personally in your private Equity what's
catching your eye what are you doing um
well yeah so it's not
necessarily a sector specific strategy
you know we're fairly sector agnostic
although you know we wouldn't uh we
wouldn't buy a restaurant although my my
business partner Adam and I were
actually investing in our favorite
little restaurant in in Baltimore but
that's more of a passion project more
more than an lbo so you know we wouldn't
buy hotels or or retail stores or
anything like that apart from that
working to look at any deal in any
sector what we do look for though which
is really really important is we're
looking
for a distressed seller of a good
business not the other way around there
are plenty of good sellers of distress
businesses businesses that are not
making any money they have you know not
very strong balance sheets not very good
customer reputation we want a business
that's really solid it's um not
declining it's at least got kind of flat
revenues or it's growing it's profitable
it's got a strong balance sheet it's got
a good customer base good product good
reputation in the market but it's the
seller of that business that's
distressed they either want to retire
they could be sick sadly they could be
dying in some cases which is awful or
they could just be burnt out or tired or
or frustrated or they just run out of
ideas inside of their business and
they're essentially you know they've
checked out of that business in their
mind it's just a case of them getting
that deal done and sadly most business
owners that get into that space end up
just turning the lights off closing the
door
and walking away and unfortunately
letting their employees go and letting
their customers down and in some cases
having to pay money out of their
retirement to actually shut the business
down because the business has got
liabilities and leases and bank loans
and all those different things it's
actually a lot easier and cheaper for
them to give it to somebody like me for
a dollar and I can keep running the
business and taking it forward so that's
what we're really looking for it's it's
that good business that's got that kind
of Highly motivated seller that's really
Keen to kind of exit and go and do
something with the rest of their life
and it's not necessarily A retiree even
though as I mentioned before there's
10,000 Baby Boomers retiring every day
and according to Forbes 19% of them own
a small business so you've got 1,900
businesses every single day coming to
Market to be sold just in the United
States uh but what we're really looking
for is just that that kind of distress
seller that wants that trusted safe Pair
of Hands to take their business and kind
of it's it's like it's like giving away
your child you know I don't know if if
you've ever had to give away like an
animal I had a dog once and um I was
moving from a house and I was getting
divorce moving from a house moving into
an apartment and sadly you know I
couldn't take my dog with me so I didn't
want to take the dog out the back and
shoot it put it down I wanted to rehome
that dog with a loving caring family
that would give my dog a wonderful rest
of its life and for a lot of business
owners it's the same kind of feeling
they want to make sure that their
business outlives them and goes to the
next level it's all about their their
kind of legacy and their kind of love
and support for the employees that have
been there to help them build that
business if you sell the business to a a
safe Pair of Hands then you they're
really fulfilling that requirement so
Carl I read your bio um and you've got a
a really Rich business history so I can
see how someone could be watching you
talk and go okay it's a great idea I can
see how it can be done I can see how
Carl can do it yeah is it really
feasible that an everyday guy can do
what the average go yeah absolutely so
as long as they've got a little bit of
business understanding and they're
trying to do deals in sectors that they
know and they understand then really the
rest is all about mindset it's all about
your purpose and your why you know I've
mentioned before the liks of coor and
there's Wayne tiker and Chris Matthews
and all the kind of students that have
come through our program they wanted to
buy businesses because they wanted to
get out of whatever they were currently
doing so they were in a nin to5 they
didn't like they wanted to make more
money they wanted more control over
their their career and their life they
wanted a work life balance so they could
spend more time with their family and do
those different things so it's all
really the mindset and people look at me
and think well he's been doing this all
of his life he knows how to do deals
he's worked on Wall Street he's got all
these qualifications it makes no
difference if you can if you understand
how business really works and you know
the particular sector that you want to
go in the rest of it is all about
mindset and it's giving yourself enough
leverage to take you out of what you're
currently doing and to become the buyer
and the owner of a business because
what's interesting is people actually
they don't want to buy a business they
actually don't want to own a business
they want the benefits of what owning a
business means for them whether it's
money whether it's Pride whether it's
that work life balance and some of the
other benefits that owning a business
can give you when you go from an
employee to an employer yeah we talked
with the Robert kisaki's accountant and
his number one tax advice is to own a
business there are many benefits to
owning a business you you talked about
mindset and you know the mindset of the
you potential business owner I'm
thinking about the mindset of the the
seller that and so you mentioned this
briefly but I want the psychology yeah
that that seems to be really important
to yeah if I'm not paying this seller
his best price at all cash up front I
think the exchange can you talk to us
about how you work yeah absolutely so
imagine two identical businesses so they
have the same product or service uh
they're in the same building they've got
the same employees and they've got the
exact same Financial profile those
businesses are completely identical the
only difference is the psychology of the
owner of that business so this guy could
be a 30-year-old entrepreneur he's
having a lot of fun he's running that
business you know every business is for
sale for the right price you know if you
had a trillion dollars you can go and
buy Google or Facebook but this
entrepreneur he might want to sell for a
much higher price and he wants most of
that money at closing the same business
could be run by somebody that wants to
retire they could be under ill health or
they're just frustrated and pretty much
done with their business that person
might even let you take that business on
and just pay them over time or pay them
a much smaller amount of money at Clos
in using the financing that's inside of
the business so those deals small deals
they're really 90% psychology and 10%
numbers when you're working on like a
hundred million deal and I did lots of
those back in my corporate life they're
90% numbers and only 10% psychology
those are processes of of financial
engineering so really when I talk before
about the perfect seller it's that
distress seller that highly motivated
seller of a really solid business
they're not necessarily financially
motivated they might want a little bit
of money especially paid over time but
for them it's about can they find a
buyer that's going to protect their
legacy and basically take their business
to the next level and they'll cheer them
on from the sidelines my first deal that
I ever did my my first very very first
lbo deal when I came out of the
corporate world kind of encapsulates
that point so when I um when I I changed
my career from being a a corporate slave
which I think I was to an entrepreneur I
decided to become a business broker so
this was back in 2008 and I started I
set myself up as a business broker and
my first deal that I got to basically
sell to somebody else was a Transport
company so I went down there and I met
the two owners Colin and Allen they were
the owners of the business and they said
well you sell the business for us we
want a lot of money we want to retire
yada yada y so I created the kind of
sales perspectus the document started
contacting lots of larger companies so
really if you own a business it's it
should be quite easy to sell that
business to a larger competitor that
you've got and that's what I did so I
contacted a load of those businesses I
went and made my pitch and then one of
them came back with a really attractive
offer to buy the business so the
brothers were really happy they were
going to both get a couple of million
pounds each very very happy and um
the kind of deal went through so they
were doing due diligence and doing all
the various work and it was the night
before the closing of the deal so this
was the Thursday night and I'm in my
office in my house I worked from home
back in the day and I'm just going
through the checklist and making sure
I've got all my ducks in a row because
it was the closing uh day tomorrow and
it's about 8:00 at night and Colin Rings
me and this is a big Gruff kind of north
of England man in his 60s and he was
crying I said what's the matter he said
we've pulled the deal and all of a
sudden my heart sank because as a
business broker you make most of your
money on a contingent fee when the
business sold so instantly I just lost
200 Grand as my fee for closing this
deal I said you know why why why not why
why aren't you going through with a deal
he said well come down come down and
talk to me so I went down into the
business and the whole team was there
there's about 45 people there they
brought all the the drivers in they'd
had a big meeting to basically decide
that they didn't want to go through with
the sale because the trade buyer the
competitor the larger business that was
coming in was basically going to gobble
them up asset strip it get rid of all
the employees all they wanted was the
trucks and the customers they didn't
want anything else and the Legacy that
these two brothers had built over 35
years you know they've gone through some
really painful times starting and
growing and making that business
successful all their employees had
supported them they didn't want to see
their life's work disappear in a puff of
smoke and then to go and retire and sit
on a beach sipping cocktails knowing
that their employees couldn't make their
mortgage payments couldn't put food on
the table so they pulled the deal and
they looked at me and said you've got to
go out Carl you've got to find somebody
that's not going to do that it could be
an individual it could be a small
management team that you can find that
can come and can buy our business and I
don't know what possessed me I'm stood
there all these faces are looking at me
and I said I'll buy your business and
then I thought what have I just said
I'll buy you business and they looked at
me and said well you don't know anything
about this industry you're a business
broker I said I know but I know enough
because I've been working on this deal
for six months I know how your numbers
work I know how you make money I know
how you recruit customers I know how
your supply chain and all your Logistics
works I know everything about your
business I will buy your business
now I'm not going to be able to offer
you anywhere close to what the
competitor was offering you but if
you'll allow me I'm going to use your
balance sheet the value of your trucks
the real estate I can raise some money
I'll pay you that as a closing payment
and then I'll pay you so much per month
over three years and I looked at the
operations manager I looked at the head
of sales and I looked at the financial
controller and I said I'm going to give
each one of those three 10% of the
company and we'll run it together and he
looked at me and he said I'll give you
30 days if you can make that work you
can have the business and everybody
started cheering and applauding they
were like great and we did that deal
that was my first ever leverage buyout
deal as an individual and basically it
was just
circumstance if the trade buyer would
have gone through with that deal I
probably wouldn't be doing this today
still be a business broker so yeah that
was my first ever deal and the kind of
moral of that story is 79% and I I did
my own survey on this 79% of small
business owners don't necessarily want
to sell for financial reasons some of
them do our system weeds those people
out they want to sell their business for
other regions they want that safe
trusted Pair of Hands bit like the dog
story that can take their business and
take it to the next level Safeguard the
employees protect the Legacy that
they've built inside of the business and
basically take that business to the next
level that's terrific inside that you
mentioned a a good buyer for businesses
is is one of their competitors and I
know this is something you're starting
to do you know yeah I helping
entrepreneurs grow their own business
through acquiring can you talk about
that yeah so it's really interesting if
you look at the kind of firsttime
entrepreneur their pain and frustration
is they're trapped at a 9et to-5 they
want more money time Freedom all those
different things if you own a business
already you can double the size of your
business and More in one day by
acquiring a business that's either
directly competing with you so going
down the street and buying your nearest
competitor you can buy a company that's
in a complimentary market so if you're
uh if you own a software company you can
go and buy a hardware company and you
can sell the software to the hardware
customers and vice versa so you're
double in your business and at the same
time as you bring two businesses
together there are lots of duplicate
costs that you can take out of your
combined operation namely the cost of
your premises and insurance and maybe
not all of the employees will want to
stay there's lots of things lots of
costs that you can take out what you can
also do is if say you're a manufacturer
you can buy companies in your supply
chain so if you're making like steel
components and a lot of your stuff go
out and say a cardboard box you could
buy the Box manufacturer and you can buy
all those different things if you own a
hotel go and buy a dry cleaning business
because then that can serve both sides
of the businesses that you're in so
there's lots of reasons why small
businesses will buy other businesses
because it solves three of their biggest
challenges you know number one it's
becoming harder to grow a business
customer by customer you know you can if
you've got a th customers today and it's
took you 10 years to get to that point
you can add another thousand in 90 days
by just going and buying another
business um as well when you bring those
businesses together and there's a lot of
cost savings to be made then you're
going to increase the cash flow that's
going through your business that's
another challenge that a lot of small
businesses have but maybe the even
biggest challenge is it's becoming
really difficult for small business
owners to find and retain really good
talent really good people which is why a
lot of small business owners they're
actually they don't really have a
business they just have a job in their
own business they're doing all the work
inside of that business they're working
in their business when they should be
working on their business so by buying
another small business you've maybe got
a ready-made general manager that can
come in and run the combined operation
so that then really you can become like
a dealmaker CEO you can come in and just
work on your business and be looking at
joint ventures other deals and not
having to worry about the daytoday kind
of operations of the business brilliant
Carl I can't thank you enough for being
here I really appreciate you sharing
your experience thank
[Music]
you next up we have Anne Wilson founder
of the wealth Chef an went from being
deep in debt to financially free in just
years and she's ready to show you how to
quickly eliminate debt from your life
too plus Ann's ready to reveal why no
one ever became wealthy from a paycheck
even if you're a doctor or lawyer making
hundreds of thousands a year here's
an an I'm very much looking forward to
this conversation something tells me
it's going to be a little Lively I think
it could be well you know got to make
money sexy cuz it is
money is sexy huh have you always felt
that way certainly not no felt really
well firstly growing up very waspish
family but I think in many families it
was almost a Deo something out there you
didn't really speak about it there was
something a little bit dirty about it
yeah you know there would be phrases
like the nvo re I had no idea what that
meant but you definitely didn't want to
be one of those because there was sort
of shaming around it and so real
confusion around it of money you know
don't ask for it because that came at a
cost or being greedy so was certainly
anything but sexy when we talk about
growing up you have an accent where are
you from so really confused accent but I
am I'm African through and through I'm
from South Africa and I grew up at at
the height of aparte wow which I think
really also has had a very big influence
on me as well around the relationship
with
money access to opportunity
have have not scarcity and abundance and
yeah so South Africa is
is you cut through African I am so this
is interesting because you started to
talk about how growing up you know
during the time of apartheid you know
that influenced your thinking probably
around wealth and and abundance and you
know scarcity and all those you know
variables that have to do with wealth um
do you think that that's true for
basically everybody that their
circumstances in growing up probably
plays a big role in their outcomes with
wealth I think our circumstances have a
enormous impact our our immediate family
circumstances our our
socioeconomic framework about beliefs
cultural out schooling potentially
religious sides and The Wider
socioeconomic factors that happen in
countries and times I think of what's
also happening in economic Cycles
and all of those if we don't bring
Consciousness to them or are able to
realize that they construct these
Frameworks of almost
slavery that are
formed will just drive us in a in a in a
certain direction and for most people
it's not a direction of wealth and it's
not a direction of abundance it's one
generally will go to either fear or
greed or not enough right so let's talk
about then your story you know how did
you get to be doing what you're doing
was it your childhood dream or did you
kind of end up here in a way that was
unexpected I think definitely ended up
here in an unexpected way but the seeds
were planted pretty young the the the
questioning of and as I mentioned sort
of a part at growing up and seeing these
huge different extremes of just access
of privilege and real confusion as to
why that shouldn't shouldn't be and
although white privileged still grew up
in a very lower middle class kind of
family where Dad worked hard for the
money there was very much that role very
role segregation between the money
aspect I'm one of six kids number five
of six and so Mom looked after the kids
so there was that modeling MH and very
much the story of dad worked really hard
was always exhausted was always tired
making money was a struggle and it
required sacrifice
and so there was that base aspect you
didn't really speak about it you didn't
ask too much for it if you you wanted
that extra thing the conversation was
don't be greedy that would come at
somebody else's cost so whilst there was
this privilege there was also this
confusion around you must work hard for
it it's painful it's sacrificing and
then um my father died relatively young
and I got to watch my mom who had done
her role which was look after let's say
the household budget and the kids
suddenly grappling with the longer term
and let say the bigger picture Financial
well-being stuff which she had never
been skilled in that was always
something the man my dad looked after
and I noticed not only her but many
other women her compatriots her friends
actually there was this underlying deep
anxiety about money in many women and
just hoping that the person they went to
they could trust hoping it would somehow
work out and and I really I remember my
mom mom at one point and I getting a bit
emotional but I literally sitting there
and saying I hope I run out before the
money does well she had this pile of
money but this complete I don't know
what to do with it and at that point I
went I've never going to be that
vulnerable so that really started that
seat of going I'm not going to be in in
that place but the only thing I'd been
told was work hard sacrifice get the
good job it seemed like my dad sort of
had it sorted the men did and so I
studied engineering I went to go and do
civil engineering not because I gave a
damn about how steel bends or a concrete
Cube crushes but I thought that was
going to be the safe route yeah and I
think that's one of the big challenges
that was the only money education I'd
got was earn well well and then
hopefully you'd be okay so I did that
and got the job and with the job I got
the credit card and the overdraft and
the bank offering me this and then the
car and it felt like a nanoc I was deep
in debt wow and trying to do the right
thing there's there's a lot of Seduction
there isn't there because I I noticed
the same thing too when I got out of
school suddenly like I'm I had you know
and they were really good at knowing how
to get their list and to promote but
it's like you know suddenly all these
things came at you for credit to acquire
things and uh and it's it's very
seductive hugely seductive and I'm going
to take it a step further I think
there's almost a message that if you
don't have that you're not worthy right
you're not successful you're not going
to be loved you're not going to find
that partner you're not going to succeed
you don't measure up you don't measure
up and that there's debt and consumer
debt has become so normalized in our
society that it's almost to not have
debt you you're the freak M you're weird
yeah um and it's starting younger and
younger you know teens now able to get
it we could we could go a whole path
down student debt consumer Deb I mean
it's absolutely
devastating so you ended up getting in
all this debt once you got a job and
then wow the supposed anxiety and
Financial Security that I wanted was
anything but I was working for everybody
else and my my father had died of cancer
and so IID had some time to be with him
when he was dying and he had said
something to me he said and you know
life goes past in a heartbeat it's going
to be gone before you know it live have
Adventures go out there do things and
that was in a second conversation really
stuck and I went well hang on I thought
I was doing the right thing I'm earning
this money but now I can't do any of the
things I want to do I'm feeling anything
but free MH and there was this two this
deep desire for freedom and life and
expression and appreciation that it was
so
short then really went hang on this I've
got to do something about this consumer
dat and a fierce sort of reaiming of of
myself and I knew I had to be pretty
radical how old were you about at this
time so I was now in my mid 20s and I I
had just got married and I had no idea
how to have money conv ation well there
was completely you know something you
didn't do so which was only after I was
married I mean I look back now and it
feels almost embarrassing only once I
was married did we really do the big
reveal of I'll show you you know mine if
you show me yours you don't recommend
that I don't recommend that and I
realized he was even worse at this money
stuff with me he was deeper in debt so
because this is kind of important maybe
something you think about so here I am
I'm in a marriage a new marriage and and
now there's money circumstances around
that especially debt yeah um does that
impact the relationship does it redefine
it what happens absolutely and it has
it's it's one of the most Insidious
Weavers of judgment shame lack of trust
in relationships and the biggest chall
just like we're not taught about how to
manage money invest we most of us are
not given Frameworks or examples coming
back to what is our fam's you situation
of how to have empowered money
conversations do we even know how to sit
down and have a financial plan that
actually represents two
individuals as well as the relationship
as a third entity how you going to
invest how you going to manage it and so
it's no wonder that it money is cited as
the number one reason for relationship
breakdown so how did you end up then
from being a civil engineer in a new
marriage with a lot of Consumer Debt to
now doing the work you're doing today
you so managed to climb out of that dead
hole really then focused on and and went
really radical was there a light bub
moment it was a complete light bulb i'
remember that conversation when I've got
to change but I then swung and went okay
no Consumer Debt work hard there was
still this huge gap about I I had I knew
nothing about the world of assets and
investing so we actually ended up I was
working in Hong Kong gone there working
on a big project now I was in the if I
can just control my myself and my
desires and not spend any money then
maybe sometime in the future I can do
some of the things I really want to do
just this pen SW austerity
completely and it all just blew up in a
big messy money drama so my marriage
blew up all this money I'd been trying
to hold on to walked out the door with
the
marriage and and there were two big
learnings from that I had no idea what
there was I had no idea what enough was
so there was this TR trying to create
Financial safety trying to create enough
but having no idea what enough was never
knowing well where does the role of
actually living when does that come
along and I think so people get end up
just getting stuck in that place yeah
and forgetting even what life is for
them and so I was obviously a bit of a
slow learner I needed a few of these
Wake Up ca but it was then sitting in
Hong Kong alone the money had now gone
I'd been working for well over 10 years
in a supposedly good career and
going
zero and after the initial shame and
judgment and that's you know for a lot
of woman that can be a big issue around
that side I realized hang on maybe it's
not just because I'm blond and stupid
maybe there's a gap that I haven't been
taught and I I'd heard a bit about the
stock market and assets but knew nothing
about it so it started a hang on there's
a difference between earning money
spending it mhm but creating wealth is a
whole different well how is it different
side because lot of people say okay I
got to earn and save that's how I create
wealth and that is the the devastation
nobody earns their way to wealth or
freedom and nobody saves their way to
Freedom they some the two most Insidious
lies it's actually what do you do with
the money you've earned not in terms of
saving savings got a role but it's how
do you convert that or create these
amazing things called assets you
literally I felt like I had there'd been
this parallel world like a a Disneyland
of wealth that I never knew existed and
when I got curious and I opened back
this curtain was this the world of
assets asset generated income growth
Capital which seemed like there was this
private club of the Insiders who knew
and and for for many centuries it has
been an Insider Club the access to it
was lots of money privilege
inside and knowledge and it felt damn
scary cuz it felt like I wasn't meant to
even know about this but I started and I
started first with a stock market
learning about Equity investing assets
then I got into investment property then
loow input businesses and I slowly
learned about these different asset
classes and built up till the point
where well actually eight years from
that day of zero in Hong Kong going hang
on there's another way I achieved the
point where my had enough assets that
could pay for my lifestyle indefinitely
forever and that then started a real
different journey of going
realizing how many people never get to
experience that privilege that freedom
that that choice that comes with this
knowledge and that was really this the
real start of I want to share this and
how do I do that and so the the whole
business that I is the wealth shift and
TV programs and books and everything's
all came out of that that deep desire to
share I'm curious cuz in some respects
it sounds like this was kind of an
incremental Journey you started with
like you know one thing and then another
another and in other respects it sounds
like maybe you had an epiphany so was
there a breakthrough moment or did you
just sort of take your first step on the
road saying I need to learn more about
maybe I've heard about stocks in the
market and then I've heard about real
estate so was it suddenly aha I'm going
to go out and get this or was it more
incremental for you I think that was
quite a
powerful wow there's a whole world here
in this middle that I have no clue about
it and almost a deep relief that it
wasn't just cuz I was getting it wrong
that it wasn't about let me try and work
harder and earn more can I live on less
so there was was this deep relief that
there was actually a whole Gap that I
could get so that was a real epiphany of
it did feel like a whole new world come
in but then it it was going okay I know
nothing about this world so it was
tentative steps initially into it and
going well where do I start but there
was a lot of excitement enthusiasm but I
felt quite alone initially so I read
books and some books were all about
motivation and mindset and manifesting
and they'd get me all revved up and yay
and then I'd go but what do I actually
do or I'd pick up some investing book
and they were fantastic for
insomnia but it just felt like it proved
that this wasn't for the world of me it
was just formulas and and yeah just
boring as hell right and there was a key
learning in that first initial stage I
really had to learn the difference
between trading and
investing and I was so hungry to try and
find this way and I still working
full-time um that I was looking for that
that
one hit wonder that investment that's
now going to make me Rich that thing
that's going to load up and I fell for
some of the frogs that didn't turn into
princes those getrich quick kind of
schemes and I think there can be a real
danger in that stage in that feeling
like oh I i' I've waited so long or I've
left it too late and did you say that it
was eight years that you went from where
you were at zero for the most part to
saying that you were able to now say i'
I've created assets where I don't have
to work to support my lifestyle y That's
pretty fast it is fast and what's so
interesting a lot of people go eight
years you mean so
slow because there is a lot of that
mentality of wanting this Lottery this
kaching event I want this
overnight getrich quick side and 8 years
is quick and in that very first year I
was looking for that kaching event and I
actually fell for one particular scam in
Hong Kong which was this buy this disc
and it's going to tell you what to buy
exactly and you're going to have these
crazy returns cuz now I was learning
that return was important there was
these Investments and um in hin I I mean
I was deeply embarrassed when I realized
I'd been scammed and it could have been
so easy to have gone into the well this
isn't for me look go back lose
confidence and that shaming side was
really
going okay let's get the greed monsters
down and that there's this sustainable
path and way
and I'm very grateful I then stumbled
across good old John ble and Vanguard
and I learned about index tracking very
early really there are these bundled
Investments so now we want to invest in
the stock market so I thought this is
going to be the easiest thing for me to
invest in while I'm still working
full-time and I knew property was there
but I thought let me f first focus on
this area and there were these mutual
funds bundled Collective investment
schemes which most retirement funds
Investments are in but they come with
layers of fees on and there's this whole
concept that there's a financial advisor
well a financial manager who makes a
selection and they're very clever and
they're going to be able to beat the
market and as a result you're going to
get these returns and thank heavens you
darling
blonde woman or man or whoever you know
this finan things is very confusing so
let us the very generous financial
industry take care of this complicated
thing for you I'm very G forit you can
see I've got a little bit of skepticism
about the financial industry but
essentially there's these actively
managed funds which are aiming to beat
the market so you but you've got to be
paying these managers fees and so John
burgle
um who was a founder of Vanguard and was
a fund house so in in the' 70s just
really went hang on let's challenge this
assumption that doing all this activity
and these actively managed funds are we
actually beating the market right we we
arrogantly assuming we are but has
anybody actually tested this assumption
and he took a whole lot of analysis and
he realized that most funds failed to
beat the market in other words all of
this activity going on all these people
paying to be these experts they didn't
achieve just what the average stock
market was returning mhm and it was like
well that's a bit embarrassing but what
can we do about it and so he created the
very first index tracker so an index is
just well simply put the stock market is
just owning a slice of somebody else's
business you can own a piece of somebody
else's business without having to pitch
up for a day's work M you don't have to
take the risk and you know you benefit
from both the Capital Growth and the
income in terms of dividends and so
these slices of business are bought and
sold on a stock exchange just like the
supermarket but it happens to be at the
stock exchange and so an index is just
saying that particular exchange or a
portion of it what is if you just bought
all of the shares bought and sold on
that exchange mirrored it and you put
that into a fund and so you didn't need
supposedly this expert buying and
selling you could strip away the costs
how would that
perform and so the birth of index
tracking came about where typically your
index funds will
outperform between 80 and 85% of your
actively managed funds predominantly
because you're getting the market return
but you're cutting out the costs right
which are the things that eat in so
stumbled across these and they I'm
deeply grateful they they still form a
large part of the base of my wealth and
my freedom and so I started in that so
there was this incremental way and I was
trying to do these octopus on road
escate things you know I was still in
that way thinking I could control and if
I did more complicated things but as I
actually evaluated I realized that
consistency that sticking with the
strategy those were actually far more
powerful than anyone let me try this let
me do this crazy stuff and a huge big
lesson came along that actually what I
needed to do was put in place just
systems and processes that could protect
my money from
me that's an interesting comment you had
to protect your money from yourself but
that's probably true for a lot of people
right they're their worst enemy when it
comes to developing wealth absolutely we
fiddle we get arrogant or we get
impatient or we get afraid or we get uh
you know how could I put it lustful for
certain extravagances that are not
really properly affordable yeah and so
we'll dive in and sabotage we'll Rob
ourselves so maybe we start an investing
plan and then an emergency comes along
we believe it's emergency you know
sometimes it could be a real emergency
so it was important to realize well what
are these ways to protect me from me one
from the
emergency expect those unexpected events
plan for them so I don't then sabotage
MH my my wealth then systems and process
absolutely I mean I I am a bit of an
adrenaline junkie and I know I'll and I
I'm going to completely own I could be
pretty arrogant at times I think you
know the ego can come in and think I can
maybe do better here or
fiddle and so I really learned get my
Thrills elsewhere let my investing be
boring be consistent
those are things I can control and once
I had this recipe this this just Bas
application over and over and over again
then I moved to the next asset class
that's an that's an an interesting um
premise or or maybe even a quote is a
let my investments be boring uh so
because that's the whole thing like if
it's boring and it's just you know
producing incrementally all the time
that can get very boring and people then
maybe do get impatient especially you
people that that need stimulation in
their life so so that I think that's a
really interesting strategy saying let
me get my Thrills somewhere else but not
for my investments absolutely and I talk
about a a freedom pyramid so laid out
for us so maybe the engineering mean is
the bit of the geek in terms you know
your pyramid especially a foursided
pyramid is is the most stable structure
in the world good enough for the
Egyptians but really looking at saying
how do I design
my investments my portfolio in a way
that's really solid that can stand
whatever life throws at it because money
and wealth is never going to protect us
from life it's not meant to be you know
the aim of wealth is not to now suddenly
live in a Land of unicorns farting
flowers and end asde I think the aim of
it is to be able to be fully present
with everything that life brings in
having this real amazing solid base that
we can rely on and so the pyramid
structure is a solid broad base but it's
got a big fat asset base
yes it's all about the
base no treble in this so the foursided
pyramid is going there four primary
asset classes and going how the the more
asset types different kind of assets we
can bring into our life the more
stability we have so we're not also just
relying on one kind of Market just
property or just business or just Equity
or just Commodities how do they fit and
work together so the broad classes being
the equity class so owning other
people's businesses right the second
side of that pyramid being investment
property real estate in various forms
the third side is is is passive or
residual businesses I don't like the
word passive I think it's businesses
where we use systems and processes and
leverage to do the value exchange so we
not have to be in a job have a business
and it's such a great wide um Range I
mean literally in all of these areas we
realize there's so many opportunities
but on the loow input business side in
the physical world it could be things
like having a range of vending machines
so you have these vending machines which
churn and deliver the value for you
automated car washers laundr mats you
that's in the physical world the the
internet has created unprecedented
opport unities to also create lwi input
residual businesses on digital products
knowledge-based businesses where systems
and processes tools can deliver the
content the video that side of things um
e-commerce Amazon wholesale there's such
an amazing range but the principle the
key principle is there is that there's
systems processes and other people
usually lower input costs that can
operate a model and a system that can
keep delivering the value and bring the
money in which is really important point
for me money is all about value exchange
you've got to deliver the value first
and comes back every asset because if an
asset isn't delivering value it's not
really an asset and it's not going to be
sustainable so that's the third side of
of this pyramid and the fourth side is
ourselves you know we truly are our
greatest assets and for most of us when
we start off yes there's that aspect of
exchanging our own time for money m and
I think it's super important to not
shame that because I think it's great
privilege to be able to deliver value to
the world through our own time and
energy and I think it's part of giving
meaning to life but it's so important
that that's not our only option so we
have flexibility but also this side of
the pyramid is also deeply important is
just Knowledge and Skills we don't know
what we don't know so we need to be
expanding that but also our our mindset
unweaving those Frameworks that we spoke
about that we socialized into grow so we
actually can create that but then with
this Freedom pyramid it's saying what is
the kind of Investments that going to be
at the base of my pyramid and this is
going to be the bulk of the boring
consistent put it on automation
autopilot protected from ourselves with
you know 13 locks and bolts and we can't
get to it and then we can move up the
pmit to slightly more volatile assets
where and I'm not even going to use the
word speculation Maybe a bit more
volatility potentially um having to get
involved a bit more in terms of
evaluating and then we come right to
that tip tip tip of the pyramid and it's
a tiny little tip whereas we can allow
ourselves some speculation maybe some
fun this is where we can bring in the
likes of the cryptos or the pot stocks
or the Angel Investing startups or if
you want to add some Collectibles like
watches if that's really what you into
but it's this discipline of having a
structure which provides a framework to
gain ensure it's safe and having
scientists say okay that tip of that you
can't start working on the tip of your
pyramid if you don't have the foundation
in place and in that kind of Ascension
um from the base to the tip uh so you're
saying and just to kind of reiterate a
little bit so you're saying on the
equity side or on the stock side you're
looking at indexes are the base and then
is something between indexes and crypto
yeah I think you know there's indexes
based but also at the bottom there
there'll also be some cash mhm so stay
almost when I'm saying that Equity side
I'm also really talking about some the
intangible assets there's you can also
be adding some loan instruments or bonds
I'm not a huge again because I'm a bit
more of a spe that adrenaline junk me
find Bond super boring but I forced
myself to have some of those kind of
really boring stuff in there so that
forms part of that really solid base the
middle side for me is more direct share
investing so we might do some stock
picking with some specific strategies it
might be value investing contrar in
maybe some shorter term trading I I I've
done I tried the day trading kind of
week trading thing and that's why I
really realized big difference between
trading and investing oh yes um now I'm
9 9% an investor I'm looking for growth
and and income is there a percentage of
allocation from you know the base you
know as far as if you say these are
let's say they're three strata you know
the very base you know kind of really
boring stuff maybe some trading or or
picking some stocks and then you know
then the the speculative stuff like
crypto yeah there is well certainly it
also depends where we are on our journey
and where and on are we at the feasting
off stage draw down stage are we just
starting out because when we're just
starting out it's going to be really
hard to get a a balanced portfolio
that's spread because there's also
balance
between equity and tangibles property
loow input businesses and also ourselves
making sure we also having fun directing
some money to to life and the things
that actually make wealth and life
wealthy now that's a whole another side
but within that I really see that bottom
base is a good 70% of that pyramid it
really is a broad solid structure you've
got that real solid base is that true
mathematically incidentally you know it
is you know and and and in many of of
your buildings like your um the that
huge big building in Dubai the Burge
Khalifa yeah 70% of the budget and the C
is actually once below the ground wow
inable to go up you know so there is
this real par there yeah do we have that
solid stuff the stuff that we don't see
that isn't sexy that's never going to
get woohoo look what I've got right but
it's the foundation for everything else
to to to stay and stand so I think in
terms of each of the you've got 70% in
the solid good old Mr misaki wax on wax
off kind of side good
15% well actually sort of more like 20
to 25% in this middle maybe midcaps
maybe more specialized asset classes and
then five to maximum 10% in that cap so
uh there's a a school of thought when it
comes to all this that is very
conservative saying the way to get ahead
or to create Financial Freedom is to
have no debt you know get out of all
debt um have savings plans and just keep
those Savings in a very safe safe and
protected place so it's it's austerity
it's it's basically saying you know
don't take that vacation necessarily
don't buy that car that cost a little
bit more it's just bring everything down
where you're almost it's very
constricting uh and while you had it put
your dreams and your life in the bottom
draw because that's that you know just
wait until you grow up kind of then you
will know right kind of Devastation yeah
and so I think there's a real difference
for me about austerity
contraction the scarcity based fear if I
really can control myself in life then
I'll be safe but there's no life there
there's no welfare and that's why I use
the word wealthy very consciously
because that for me is about a way of
being to be able to be with life do you
have a definition of wealth that you
utilize for me being wealthy is being
able to have the resources to be fully
present with
life and to be able to
respond to it in a fully engaged way to
be able to
explore Curiosities to be able to be
there for the
devastations to really have the
privilege of living Our Lives as much as
we can fully with these resources of
money serving us as fuel coming in not
slaving and saving us right and so when
we startop talking about this you know
have we just put our life and our hopes
and our dreams in a bottom draw because
then we'll be safe that's not being able
to live and so truly wealth is being
able to also come out and go at its call
having to really do some deep stuff
about going what do I actually want what
is wealthy for
me and so whilst we can build up assets
and these are key part of the S there's
another whole part of this equation
which is about us which is some real
work of going do I know what I really
want how much of the things that I'm
spending my time my energy my money on
is just
default or in an or in an attempt to get
validation and be shown that I'm you
know prove that I'm worthy
externally or because I'm just following
this this framework that I thought I
should do to to fit in and you know I
think truly wealthy is where we can come
out into the world and explore and do
things because we know we're already
enough because we truly understand that
every single one of us is just born
worthy just by having breath we already
are
and then we go and do what we want as an
expression of that rather than from so
much of what we taught and now with
money is woven through it that we do a
whole lot of things to try and prove
worthiness and that will never get us
there so for me it's a it's a it's a
middle path between really being
conscious so take debt for example
Consumer Debt is devastating and
especially when it's driven out of
belief
of trying to prove to be worthy or
trying to or believing that's our only
way this unconscious choice but there's
also neutral debt so things like for
most people we'll get a mortgage on a
home to own but are we choosing that
home in a way that's financially
sustainable for us you know your home is
not an asset it doesn't matter how much
Equity you've got in it you've got to
understand the difference but there can
be expansion debt where you consciously
understand money you understand the cost
of it and you choose to do borrowing to
control or or get assets so it's it's
it's not this rigid all Deb bad it's
about understanding money and
understanding the elements of it and
then you know frugality you know don't
spend how little can we spend it's it's
shifting it and going how can I become a
great wealthy spender MH and really
enjoy the back
end
I'll go you it it's all about the assets
it's all about the back end I truly
believe our wealthy life is created by
the choices we make as to how we spend
our money not how it comes in to me in
what you're describing the pursuit of
wealth seems to be a spiritual Quest y
we've been
outed and I'm obviously biased but I do
think when we truly if we if we have the
courage to dive into this world of money
wealth um and rarely and I use the word
courage because it there is courage
that's needed into it because often
times we really going to have to
challenge our own beliefs our societal
constructs what we're bombarded with by
advertising by books telling us what we
should be doing or what it means to to
be worthy wealthy enough
successful we realize that money has
become interwoven in every aspect of Our
Lives it starts with food shelter access
to opportunity then it comes into woven
into expression into Power into
creativity into relationships into our
own worthiness so when we're if we're
prepared to go down this rabbit hole
it's extraordinary it's an amazing and I
think can be one of the deepest and
greatest Journeys to back to ourselves
to rarely explore and for me I invite
everyone to go what is your unique
freaky wealth
recipe because it is going to be freaky
and it's going to need experimenting and
it's going to go yeah this is true for
me this this brings me deep Joy I I love
it but actually this I've got in just
because of default and and being
prepared to test and explore this side
whilst putting in place these systems
and investing the automation to to
provide this resource this that can can
then fund and fuel that the exploration
of life so this might seem like a
strange question but it's just occurring
to me
so much of what we're taught or shown
you know sometimes we're not really
taught it we're just shown it is that
you know going out and succeeding in
creating wealth it's a very masculine
thing and the way that you're describing
it um there's a lot of femininity in it
you know in its vibration or in its you
know energetic State um how do you see
it oh I love this
question coming right back to this
Spirit thing I I see it as also an
extraordinary journey to really get an
Exquisite relationship between each of
our own yin and yang the river banks and
the river the shiv and the Shakti the um
logos and the
AOS
and I think we have in in a world very
polarized and disconnected aspects we've
had so much of the financial world has
been put across as either this very
machismo Wolf Wall Street ra kind of
stuff and um that we have to be like
that or and it's and it's bit Cutthroat
and ruthless and and money scary and
investing you can lose
everything um so this can be this real
energy of of that side and we also have
a lot of side of if you're
creative um if you're a bit spiritual if
you like that well then you just have to
accept that um poverty is your lot and
it's almost been
glorified that money is a bit dirty and
the side so there's almost if we think
of of money as a framework there's there
can be shaming of that masculine element
and that deep shaming of the creative
element and this disconnect and I think
learning how to bring these things
together has also been a huge part in in
my path I came very much from well if I
go the masculine route if I go
engineering if I'm sensible and if I
have this then I'll be okay but there
was this deep Devastation of of Life of
expression of exploring m and more and
more as I created Frameworks which is
very much the masculine get bit getting
into right relationship not Frameworks
of suppression right but Frameworks of
support yeah and really understanding
that Frameworks create Freedom we need
that River Bank for the river to flow we
need that system without that the river
is just a big goddamn puddle yeah you
know but then how to have that in
service of life expression creativity
and when we dive into the world of
investing and assets we realize that
there many ways can be deeply creative
some of it we want to be just automated
and boring but we W want to let's say in
the investment property side if we go up
that permit there's also base of the
permit kind of stuff um in in real
estate but there can be ways of really
it it's the wealth Playdoh there's so
many things you can do with it creating
businesses and yeah so I it's this Glory
I think when we truly are on that path
of of this beautiful line of enough
MH of we're enough there is enough I
have enough
right worthy and Wealthy line of
noticing where we're being pulled to
I've got to have more out of either
greed or fear and just coming back to
that is where we've got this
beautiful
balance between the masculine and The
Feminine fascinating so this is a very
unique look at this whole thing called
wealth yeah and I think the whole you
know theme here to have a wealth
breakthrough I think really it is a look
in the mirror I think it does become you
know a soul searching type of a
phenomenon and we need structures you
know uh but but you have to figure out
who you are to be able to know how to
work the structures absolutely and you
can't Al you might have design wishes
and know this is who I am but without
Financial Resources to direct to
those it's also nothing yeah and to
really
also come and go I think there's this
whole you know money 4.0 of of where
we're at Now is really about getting
into right relationship yeah yeah and
going if we truly want to make a
difference in the world if we want to
for ourselves first then our communities
if we want to get into better the word
balance isde but right relationship with
our resources our Earth our animals our
side is not about money
bird it it's become integral to how we
represent money is completely neutral
it's tofu
MH we get to put the flavor on yeah so
when we understand we need that
extraordinary protein as part of that
input of life we need
money as part of one of the resources
that come in with oxygen and energy to
be able to express then we can respect
it and then we can come from an energy
of being custodians to it yeah and not
either dominators or just abusers well
then I could say this has been a
fascinating and very unique look at the
whole concept of of wealth and money and
uh and putting meaning around it all and
uh as well as some structure so that we
can figure out how to get to that place
uh that you've gotten to so I really
appreciate you taking the time to sit
and share that with us oh it's such a
pleasure Patrick it really is
and my dream is you know I think more
and more of of us who can have that
breakthrough and shift shift so money
Becomes of something of service the
Ripple cannot not make a difference
perfect well thank you so much for
sharing all this and it was really great
to be with you and
[Music]
you hi there it's Patrick again the
wealth breakthroughs you're seeing are
really starting to pile up we've seen so
many different paths you could choose to
lock down your own personal wealth
breakthrough into place real estate
business building buying a business
investing in in the markets it might
seem like too much information to
process but that's a good problem the
best thing you can do right now is share
this episode with your friends and
family heck share it with everyone you
know on social media that way you can
watch these episodes together compare
your notes work together and reach your
own wealth breakthroughs even faster
thanks for watching and we'll see you
for episode 4 soon take
care
hello I'm Patrick gentempo personal
finance education is sorely lacking in
America today I say sorely lacking but
the more accurate way to put it is it's
essentially non-existent Alan Aina is on
a mission to change that he's the
founder of the personal finance
education company 101 financial and an
Amazon number one bestselling author he
teaches his students Common Sense
practical downto Earth ways to take
control of money in in your life make it
work for you and get on track for the
life of your dreams this is an
information packed bonus interview and
watching what Allan has to say will
bring your personal wealth breakthrough
One Step Closer here's
[Music]
Allan Alan thanks so much for taking the
time to sit and have this conversation
absolutely abut great to be here Patrick
thank you so let's talk about your story
and background that got you doing what
you're doing tell us about where you
grew up and kind of how you evolved into
the work you're doing today yeah sure so
I uh come from a great place Hawaii I uh
I grew up in a small town on the
NorthShore of the an of aahu a town that
has 2600 people we got our first
stoplight just recently so we're we're
moving up there um but growing up in
Hawaii is beautiful but it also has its
challenges as you probably know you've
been there many times it's very very
expensive and uh you know to live and
survive it takes some some strategy and
some thinking and so uh the family
situation I came from was awesome have a
a beautiful amazing family the only
difficult thing for us was our financial
situation uh what that meant for me as a
child was I I grew up on the free lunch
program from the time I started
kindergarten till I graduated high
school we had Wick we had food stamps
and we had all these different types of
services just to survive that's why
today I Absolut I absolutely hate eating
kick cereal yeah right because that was
the only thing you go shopping for
groceries your parents okay you can only
get the thing that says WIC next to it
which was kicks Corn Flakes uh all the
stuff that had no sugar you know when
people go and visit Hawaii like you know
you get the beautiful Resorts and all
that I guess the people who actually you
know are born there you know live there
Etc uh there's not a lot of wealth I
think for the locals in general is that
is that accurate absolutely yeah so most
people are living paycheck to paycheck
and to to kind of get by families are
living together to afford the rent or if
they're lucky to actually afford the
mortgage to pay for the house and so you
know those struggles that I had growing
up really uh uh molded me into the
person that I am today is somebody
that's very passionate about personal
finance you see I I really wanted to
know how money worked and so I dedicated
a large portion of my life to figuring
things out and and once I felt like I
had enough that was starting to help me
I took all my life savings which at the
time was about $220,000 I was married we
had two little children and we were
renting a place and uh I said you know
I'm going to start uh something I'm
passionate about which is teaching
people about personal finance so I
started a small company I named it 101
Financial because I felt like that was
the beginning that was the thing that I
was missing see growing up in Hawaii I
saw this wealth I saw the nice resorts I
saw the nice cars and and things that
could be possible but I didn't see a
pathway for me to get there and I was
searching I was looking for ways to
learn and I I read all these great books
on you know how to flip houses and make
millions of dollars stocks business and
all this stuff but my concern was how do
I get to that point where I can buy a
house how do I get enough money to start
a business or get into the stock market
that was my big dilemma and so I created
uh a program that
could that was helping me that could
help others so I started this small
company and I started teaching people
and uh little did I know that there was
more people that wanted to be part of
this financial literacy movement that we
were starting to create in the islands
and is that right is that the thing is
it financial literacy because I could
imagine that when you're living paycheck
to paycheck uh you know there's you know
I guess some opportunity maybe working
at Resorts or something but you know
probably not a lot of other industry
that's got a lot of potential where you
can can you know move upward into
executive positions and have high salary
jobs cuz I I wonder the same thing you'd
be sitting say how do I even get started
to be able to do any investing Etc and
and is that the core of what you had to
figure out and once you figure it out
for yourself and say okay great what
made you want to bring to other people's
well once I started to discover what the
banks were doing to us I I was like why
don't people talk about this stuff like
what are they doing so so the banks are
I mean they're taking our paychecks
that's why they set up direct deposits
for just about everyone now why it's
free for your employer but they get your
money every Thursday night at midnight
direct deposit and every night they're
using it they're sweeping it out of our
accounts they're taking and they're
investing and they're earning interest
all while they're paying us nothing and
I started to get furious about this like
why don't people talk about this why
don't we know this stuff and does anyone
even care and so I did a lot of research
on banks I figure out how do they work
what products they offer and how can we
get some of those things to work for us
for the hardworking middle class and I
started to figure these things out and
it started to work so you started to
figure these things out what things did
you actually do personally that started
working for you okay so so when I first
started to figure this out I was I was a
renter and uh and trying to go out and
teach people about personal finance was
a little difficult when you're renting
why because people are like dude you
don't even own house and you're trying
to tell me how to manage my money and
pay off my debt well fortunately I was
able to use some of these things that
that I learned for example um when we
take our paychecks we put in our
checking account the bank sweeps it out
every night they earn interest we
basically get zero we found other tools
at the bank that I I call like we call a
debt checking account so where we could
put our entire paycheck against our debt
and suppress the balance for a day a
week or a month and by suppressing the
balance we save on what we call Daily
calculated interest why because because
the banks charge un Andi interest
against the outstanding balance and they
do it daily so we found a way to reduce
the daily balance which thereby saves us
interest every day then I would take
that interest that I would save and I'd
use that to pay down more of my
principal so I could in effect pay down
principal without having to earn more
money I was looking at my I looked at
every dime that was leave in my pocket
right you're like okay what do we spend
on groceries gas our cell phone Etc well
one of the biggest expenses that we have
is our debt payments and the biggest
piece of the debt payment is the
interest cost right so we said if we can
if we can reduce the interest cost we
could free up that money and use that to
help us pay down more principal there by
getting out of debt faster and once you
start to get out of debt faster you now
free up cash flow to be able to invest
and that's and that's what I started to
do was I took that extra money that I
had and I started to invest in real
estate and so
um we lived in this little apartment on
the North Shore of aahu it was it was
less than 1,000 square ft and um we able
to pay that house off in two years and
three months and I I use those paid it
off in two years paid it off paid off
the complete Mortgage in two years and
three months how' you do that with that
principal wow with that principle and
also with managing my cash with just
tracking every dollar coming in every
dollar going out just being aware you
see most people don't even know what's
going on in their financial lives I
think this statistic is like 78% of
people are living paycheck to paycheck
it's it's pretty scary and maybe is it a
sign of resignation you think
psychologically because I I I see that a
lot and I imagine even on the islands it
could be a lot worse basically we don't
make enough money to do really much of
anything me trying to spend all this
energy tracking a couple of bucks here
or there is not going to matter in your
case say you're saying it does matter
absolutely every every dime matters and
uh once you get into that mentality then
you start start to value your money more
you start to Value the paycheck that
you're earning from your job and once
you know how to make it work for you you
get more excited but when you don't
understand what's happening with your
money then it doesn't really matter you
know 30 years is 30 years who cares I
might be dead by the time I you know pay
off that mortgage so who cares let's
just have fun but it doesn't have to be
that way no so do you uh it's what I'm
hearing there's there's a a mindset you
know around this so when you start
working with people how much of it is
you working on their mindset versus how
much of of it is the mechanics of
following some kind of a process it's
probably 50% or more but the first thing
we do before we can change their mind
because they're already in a negative
mindset first thing we have to do is
show them their numbers get to a
starting point so we map everything out
what are you paying for this what are
you paying for this it is a little
tedious it's hard work that's why most
financial advisers don't ever get into
someone's budget
it's the dirty work but that's where it
all begins so can you uh maybe do the
walk through I'm I'm the somebody okay
walk me through the process so I I come
to you and I say okay um I've got some
debt really doesn't feel like I have
much disposable income at all um I rent
I'd like to somehow buy house one day
yeah buy a house one day and and have
some kind of Financial Security what
would I you know what are my steps what
would I do the first thing we do is we
have to create a starting line M before
we can see the Finish Line right the
finish line for you might be I want to
buy my first house well what's the
starting line which means we got to
track your income all sources of income
what are your expenses we want to list
every expense everything that leaves
your pocket to pay for something we're
going to track it and then we're going
to look at all of your liabilities what
type of debt you have credit cards car
loans mortgages maybe some student debt
and we're going to map it all out once
we have this road map and and I'll tell
you it's it's a simple thing but 95% of
people don't ever write it down it's the
craziest craziest thing but once they do
write it down they can start to see then
we start to formulate a road map
according to what they want to do now
before you buy a house probably the
biggest thing that you got to do is get
your cash flow in line and then get out
of debt and all the the best investors
in the world all preach that for
workingclass families the best thing
they can do is get out of their High
interest debt yeah Warren Buffett says
that Mark Cuban says that saki says that
you got a you got a 25% interest rate on
your card your credit card you need to
take care of that before you can buy
your first rental property right and
that's the step so let's say an aahu uh
you're the typical person that is there
that's that's making the decision to
move in this direction try to get more
uh financially abundant disciplined what
have you when you see them what's the
typical predicament as far as uh how
much do disposable income they have or
what's the what's the timeline and
effort to really be able to pay down
some debt so most people so 60 65% of
people will have a mortgage and they
will have 25 to 30 years remaining
because they had just probably gone
through a refire they just bought it so
that's so far away from them that they
they can't even comprehend that so we
create these shortterm wins for them so
we build what we call these 90-day
Financial road maps we track every
dollar coming in every dollar going out
and we do it for a minimum of 90 days
once we get them to do it for 90 days
then we go 6 months then we go to a year
and now once they have this road map now
we can start to find areas that we are
lacking in so we might be spending too
much here or we might be doing this you
know this type of activity where we
could cut down on and then we start to
say okay which debt can we attack first
and if you go by the Numbers it's always
best to pay off the highest interest
debt first and we do that in probably
95% of cases and so let's say you had a
credit card average credit card interest
rate in America is around 14 to 16% that
will pigeon hole anyone for the rest of
their life if they don't take care of
that so we go after that and then we
start to pay the minimums on everything
else once we free up that payment and we
start to attack the next all while we're
using our paycheck against our debt so
we have multiple things happening so we
got the the the track tracking going on
the road map then we got our paychecks
working for us every single day and see
once you start to teach people the why
and the how it creates a mind shift
their mind starts to change so it's it's
not a diet anymore where it goes away it
becomes a habit a new habit and then
they start to see themselves winning for
the first time ever that man my money's
working for me I'm getting ahead I paid
off this debt now what can I do I'm
going to go after the next one and then
they see Home Ownership becoming a
reality and that's exactly what happened
for me is once I saw that that struggle
of managing the day-to-day finances go
away I saw that I could attack this
mortgage and paid it off quickly and
once I did the whole world opened up for
me and within within five years I had
seven properties uh on on in Hawaii and
uh and one of those properties was a a
17 acre lot on the
NorthShore and here here's what I
realized personally is that my mind was
so cluttered with just trying to survive
at the beginning that I had no energy or
time to be able to focus on Building
Wealth and that's the problem for most
Americans they are working so hard they
come home they're struggling with the
bills and they can't ever think about
how do I build wealth right yeah so this
is interesting because what you're
saying is and maybe for lack of B you
need mind space to be able to start
building wealth and if you're
preoccupied with survival then uh you
don't really have that mind space yeah
well well as humans we're predetermined
to survive right we we we we we're in
survival mode all the time and then when
it comes to your financial life it's
always in that survival mode so people
are always stressed out they're always
worried about the next bill and how
they're going to make it and so if if
that is consuming you your mind has no
room or space or cap to think about okay
I'm going to get the next property we're
going to rent this out we're going to do
this Airbnb or I'm going to start a
business or I I'm going to I'm going to
fil my 401k you know I I consult with a
lot of uh CEOs in regards to their
employees Financial stress they're like
H we got these great these great uh
benefits but our participation rate is
so small yeah I tell why they're they're
they're they're not worried about invest
in their 401K they're worried about
making it to the next paycheck right so
when you create that mind space and and
maybe start to build it sounds like it's
a little bit of a momentum play and a
little bit of a habit play build some
momentum that's right put some habits in
and and stuff starts to unfold that's
right did you have along the way anybody
trying to discourage you in your own
Journey as far as saying well you know
what you're you're thinking too big
you're you know there's no way you can
do this listen you're a kid born in this
workingclass area you know it's very
expensive to live here you just got to
get out there and hustle and and you're
you know you're dreaming if you think
you're going to be wealthy one day yeah
you know unfortunately it happens in you
know in every Community it's the crabs
in the bucket and and that happened to
me many times with professors from my
college or coaches or just other people
that were you know so-called friends of
mine that like he's never going to make
it he's he's thinking about doing this
and that he's never going to do that and
uh I just use that as fuel yeah I just
use that as fuel to to fire my passion
and I noticed that when I first started
my passion was small I had a little bit
of passion but I had more fear than
passion right but as I started to put
work in and then I started to learn and
understand more about money that passion
grew as my knowledge and my education
grew my financial education grew and
then that fear went away and that fear
became very little very small was there
a recommendation for because I hear
about debt reduction and no doubt you
know Consumer Debt that's at high
interest is a really debilitating thing
that keeps you trapped uh I think
everybody agrees on that absolutely um
did you also uh create any like side
hustle or you find ways to try to
increase your income while you're trying
to reduce that debt you what are your
recommendations in that typically yeah
so the first step is to get that plan
once you get that plan you can start to
increase your wealth you don't
necessarily have to be completely out of
debt before you can start to build
wealth but to build wealth ultimately
it's going to start with your personal
finances if you don't have your personal
financial life down which means managing
cash flow paying down debt budgets it'll
be very hard and almost maybe
detrimental to become an investor
because that could fall back on you and
so what we've noticed is that when we
teach people and I did this myself is
learned personally in my personal life I
was able to apply that to my business
life and then into my investing so my
site hustle became investing in real
estate and uh and we've done many deals
and um and it it's interesting how
things always come back to you when it
when when it's the deal I mean is the
typical path you know when you have
someone who's um you know like working
the ways that you're describing saying
hey I'm working my way out of debt going
to start budgeting try to take some
allocated you know disposable income and
put it into Investments is real estate
do you think the best place or do you
have other uh paths that you recommend
so I I personally I I I wrote a a very
simple book and I talk about true
diversification when you build wealth
and my personal belief Bel is that you
need to diversify your entire portfolio
you see financial advisors a lot of them
almost all them tell us to diversify
which is true but they're only talking
about diversifying in one asset category
which is paper so you have stocks large
cap small cap mutual funds bonds
absolutely have to do that but they're
missing a big piece we need to talk
about true diversification across what I
consider the three major asset
categories paper real estate and
business and so I teach people to have
goals for that and obviously they choose
one that they really like and I have my
my favorites as well and then one that
you are sort of good at and you have
your third place um when you say paper
you mean stocks yes I mean stocks mutual
funds ETFs all those things and and
again be be Diversified in your paper
asset category but I suggest not leaving
out the other two major asset categories
you said real EST real estate and in
real estate there's two forms of real
estate there's cash flow real estate
which are rental properties and then
there's we call cash now properties so
these are Flips right okay and then the
third asset category is business and I I
believe everyone has a million-dollar
business idea in their in their head
locked up somewhere they just got to
pull it out and take action and do that
I like that so you think everyone has a
million dollar if I had one then I
believe everyone has one especially
coming from where I came from yeah um
being so poor growing up uh and building
a a multi-million dollar business out of
my small little apartment on the North
Shore of aahu uh building a business
that became Inc 500 in our seventh year
wow uh we were the second company from
the islands to ever make the Inc 500
list so it was a it was a big deal the
island celebrated and then uh one of the
local TV stations affiliate of Fox News
asked me to do some Financial shows for
them and it turned into eight years on
uh on the station hosting a what we call
the financial Fitness report led to a
number one best sell on Amazon and uh a
company that helps tens of thousands of
families across the country so if I can
do it everybody can do
it and I believe you when you say it I I
and see I I uh at the time when I
started I wasn't even a college graduate
wow I had dropped out of school and
there were lot people like well alen do
you have a finance gr I was like no I
was a biology
major interesting but really majoring in
basketball that's what I did I played
ball there so spent more time at the gym
than the
library um but it can happen wow so and
I sense and I think this is a very cool
thing there's a bit of sense of Pride
saying hey you know I grew up we in the
islands and uh and this is what we were
able to create um is that is that a
source of fulfillment for you oh
absolutely I I feel like I'm
representing my race uh Native haian
there's a lot of challenges uh for our
race and um you know one of those IS F
Financial it's just a big problem and
for every race for that matter but but I
feel like um I need to set an example uh
by doing things the right way for myself
and then by giving back by teaching
people and and the best thing that we
could do as you know when you when you
have kids the best thing you can leave
for your kids is to give them education
right want to send them the best schools
and all these things but what about
financial education they're going to go
to the best schools get a get a really
good job or have a business but what if
they can't take care of their money
right so that's you know the area that I
focus in on for helping families is to
provide that Financial education so in
your situation because I know now you
you've got your own personal investment
path you know you to create your your
wealth but you're also doing a lot of
Education and Training and have you
almost given permission to native
Hawaiians to say well you know he did it
and uh almost you said hey I did it so
they can too has it has it created any
kind of a movement uh in Hawaii ha on on
the idea of uh of wealth and abundance
for for native Hawaiians 100% it it has
because just like in any Community right
if you see someone that kind of looks
like you talks like you has the same
skin color as you that they're doing
certain things there's either two
emotions you're going to feel you're
going to feel a lot of jealousy or
you're going to feel like wow I that's
inspiring yeah and those that are
jealous they're going to be in that
mindset and you know hopefully they
break out of it but for those that want
to do more they have that abundance
mentality those are the ones that I want
to inspire so they can go in and change
their next Generation that's so great
and it seems like the things that you
teach and again you call it 101 like hey
it's kind of basic right the things that
you teach are not complicated to
understand it's really almost the maybe
it's the problem it's more boring than
complicated and it's hard to get people
to want to do boring stuff well yeah and
and for some reason I don't know why
they don't teach this in school right in
my personal humble opinion I feel that
money management is like the number one
life skill right if it's not number one
it's 1 a yeah but it's up there right I
mean we we all I'm not sure if you had
to do this but in Hawaii we had to take
two years of algebra yeah well who in
the world uses algebra now what a waste
of two years but I I would rather have
learned about money and investing yeah
like teach me how to buy a house when
I'm in high school teach me about
mortgages and credit scores teach me
about debt and how that's going to
affect my relationship you know I'm
married my my wife and I have seven kids
and and uh money affects many many
relationships it it's the number one
cause of divorce and then for our
children we are as parents the number
one source of financial education for
our children that's actually a really
interesting point and and I might want
to dig into that a little bit more so
now you have seven kids so I guess you
like to succeed on all levels right you
we do it big on every level you're going
to go big we're going to go big we're
going to have kids
seven is that how many houses you said
you had within about four years yeah we
had to yeah I have a whole investment
strategy behind that so I'll tell you
later so uh so you have these seven kids
and uh and now you're saying okay what
is my responsibility as a parent for
these children what are you teaching
them CU I'll tell you that there's a lot
of parents a lot of people here they are
parents and they want to learn from
themselves and they and they want to be
inspired and learn from what you're
saying but they also maybe say I also
want to learn how to be a good parent
and and be a good Steward in this realm
as far as my own family is concerned so
uh what do you teach your kids tell me
how you how you approach it well I'm not
sure if it was like this for you Patrick
when when you were growing up but it
felt like it was almost illegal to talk
to your parents about money like you
ever ask like Hey Dad how much do you
make you know what would happen like
don't don't talk about we don't talk
about that stuff right that happens for
a lot of families so in our days growing
up you know talking about money was bad
so what did that do to a child that's
seven 10 years old 15 year old asking
about money it created this negative
mindset like we don't talk about this
stuff this is is not good right I I
tried to flip the the script on that and
I I'm very open my wife and I are very
open with our kids we talk about money
we're talking about properties that
we're looking at buying like hey guys
you know this this house is for sale we
put an offer in on it what do you guys
think and we're going to rent and we we
talk about our tenants and we we have
them come over on Thanksgiving we bring
turkeys over to our tenants when they
when they move out we bring them over to
fix it up and they paint they get dirty
with us uh we bring them into
Investments remember starting my two
boys out we were doing some house uh
building on the big island of Hawaii so
we'd buy these lots and we we'd put some
money in so I said hey boys you have
some money you can invest with us so
they both put in they were four and S
years old at the time M they put $500 in
each okay so they had all we had little
savings so they put their whole Savings
in we said okay this money is going to
pay for light bulbs and your money is
going to pay for paint so they can
relate to that right and then we we did
the deal and we flipped it and I gave
him their check and I remember my son at
the time the four-year-old his name's
kavika he got his check and it included
his principal he he he invested plus his
return which was over 40% in about 7
months he was looking that that check he
is like wow I can buy more gumballs now
right I like okay no we're we're not
going to do that okay so I have this
next deal that's coming up what if you
put this money in to this deal what
could it grow into so we started
teaching them do they understand
everything now but now today that same
son kavika he and I are doing his first
deal he's um he's serving a mission
right now and and he saved up some money
so we both are splended down payment on
a house wow how's that feel 19 years old
how's that feel it feels great like I
can see it it's just it's a it's amazing
you know I have to say that I think it's
genius the idea saying hey um we got a
deal going you want to invest with us MH
uh especially at a young age uh because
I think almost every kid has some sort
of savings either that the parents kind
of said hey we're setting up a little
account you keep put a little bit of
money in it me Christmas money uh
birthday money whatever it might be but
then also uh or some kids have like just
a little stash at home what have you but
man what a difference I think that would
have made for me at a young age if
somebody said oh here i' I've got $500
and this and then sometime later I'm
getting all this money back and in the
meantime I didn't do anything except put
it and invest it and then it came back
and it was more came back bigger it came
back Big O that's bigger so that is
really and and it's interesting to say
gumballs because they're they can equate
something that they value with the size
of this check and so you that's really
I'm literally sitting here saying I
can't believe I I never thought of that
I you know with my own kids that I never
thought to to do such a thing it's just
that living experience as compared to
because I think that's what's missing
I'm recognizing oh uh you know let me
teach you about this and let me teach
you about that no how about the living
experiences say put this in and get this
back yeah I started my kids teaching
them the what we call the three SES of
money so so the money that we save the
money that we share and the money that
we spend oh talk so so when when our
kids make money so we would put them to
work you know my my wife has a camp that
she does every summer one week a year we
have them work at the camp whether
they're getting ice or doing this and
they earn a few hundred every summer and
so after a few Summers that adds up and
so we we have these these these little
trade slider trays that we got from
Walmart that had had three drawers we
had money that we save money that we
share and money that we spend and we
allocate a percentage to each drawer
right and so over time they would you
know they'd still be to have fun we're
not taking away the fund out of their
money so they can still buy the gumballs
but their savings is starting to grow at
the same time we're teaching them to
share and give back to either people
that are homeless or other people that
need help or tithing or whatever it is
and uh they started to learn the value
of money then once they had enough money
we said hey we're going to bring you
into this deal and we I did little
things to help them to understand that
now as they're older they're getting
involved in bigger deals so um right now
currently my partner and I are looking
at uh closing on apartment complex we're
going to build a 90 unit apartment
complex with commercial Frontage and so
I'm open with my kids about it I I
taught them about the deal I taught them
about how much is it's going to cost and
and a lot of parents are afraid to talk
about like how much this house is worth
or the how much rent you get we talk
about about that we have Section 8
rentals um and uh we talk about the
money that we get from section 8 and
then the tenant covers a little bit
extra we're very open and kids are
smarter than we think they are when it
comes to the money thing yeah because
they're looking and they're thinking
about it whether you know it or not you
know I know my kids uh a lot of times
like how' you you how'd you pick up on
that or how'd you know about that you
they're if we're not helping them with
that dialogue going on in their mind
then they start to assume that oh when
you have AIT I see my parents they just
get stuff when they go to the store by
putting this plastic thing in there like
money's
unlimited we have to explain to them
that you know because I learned this
early on when my my two older boys were
kids that like why don't you just write
one of those checks and you get more
money so it doesn't work that way so we
have to explain it because otherwise no
one else is going to do that for us yeah
but even and they grow up and if they
have a credit card that you give them
the same kind of thing it's like well I
just use it whenever I need it and you
know oh that's where the de cycle starts
right is when they go to college right
they get their first credit card offers
and and the credit card companies
they're very smart um we had hired this
PhD his math PhD to come work for us and
he told me this this uh this story of
how he worked for some other Banks and
he was on a committee to help design
credit card offers for college students
and their research showed that every
college student will have discretionary
$20 a month that could actually go
towards a credit card payment m so they
designed the offers and it was
preapproved with the university card and
here's how they marketed it at the
bookstore oh so any time a student made
a purchase they had a pre-approved flyer
for the credit card stapled the receipt
to that and here you go and that's where
the debt cycle starts for for kids they
just suck you in huh and and you know
and make it branding it's like and you
know because there's always when you're
under the constant strain of of fiscal
management saying hey I got very limited
resources I'm a student what have you to
to say well I might have a moment of
relief if I use this credit card it's
it's very seductive isn't it no one's
teaching them and they're giving away I
mean you know the first week on college
campus they have you know student week
and they have all the booths right so
they have you know this club to join and
this club and between all the clubs and
activities there's the credit cards yeah
the Branded credit cards from the
University and everyone's getting if you
sign up for this you get a free shirt or
a giant siiz Kit Kat bar and all the
kids like yep sign up that kid c bar but
they get this credit card and it's it's
approved for 500 bucks it's not much but
the but we got to understand what the
banks are thinking behind the scenes
look we we lock this kid in they can
afford the $20 right but when they
graduate and they get a job all we need
to do is increased their limit right now
they got 2500 right now they got 5,000
and it's branding wow it's keeping them
in the cycle is credit card debt maybe
the biggest challenge to the average
americ American right now do you think
uh that's the yeah that that's the start
of it because that's the easiest type of
credit to get cuz the banks can give you
small you know sums right and so they
get you started with that another big
problem that we're starting to see today
is uh student debt yeah massive massive
it's the student debt is has surpassed
credit card debt in America probably
about two three years ago oh wow okay so
it's more student debt than credit card
debt absolutely and the interest rates
that we're seeing is like almost double
what people are paying on their
mortgages wow just
unbelievable so now for you know if I if
I'm coming in to your program I'm
getting advice and Direction and I've
got some credit card debt and I guess
the details matter but I've got student
debt you're I imagine you're working
hard on getting that student debt also
reduced or um we're analyzing interest
rates and payments and so we're looking
okay the interest rate what is the
interest rate on this should we take
care of this one first or maybe there's
this one type of debt we can pay off to
free up a bigger payment right you have
like $400 or $500 was going to your car
payment and you're you have this much to
pay on maybe we'll knock that out first
so we free up that cash flow right and
then we use that to attack other debt
it's it's it's strategy it's just
understanding numbers and then
understanding the mentality of people
and I think part of the mentality say
Hey listen once this debts paid off
don't think oh I got this extra money I
can go spend absolutely not that's the
Temptation they'll get spanked from
Ellen right so but they don't do that
they don't want to get spanked okay but
but the way we do that and and and
honesty is we set financial goals with
them once we create that plan we have a
goal so the goal says okay look once we
get out of this debt now I can buy a
house or I already have a house I'm
going to pay it down then I'm going to
buy my first rental property and and
once you start to create these goals and
people have a pathway and they
understand they're going to do it
they're going to do it they just need to
be taught that's a big part of the
psychology isn't it because if they
don't have a goal then you they don't
have any discipline no Direction just
like anything no Direction yeah so
that's interesting so by saying hey
there's a goal out here so that's what
keeps them on the track to get to the
goal uh so that's so I guess there's
these varing pieces that you assemble uh
I'm I'm intrigued before we we just
leave the one thing any other things
about uh parents teaching their kids CU
you had the 3 s's yeah right um You you
had uh you know the thing of getting
your kids in a deal any other things
that that you think a parent might use
to help teach your kids about money the
number one thing is parents got to get
their stuff together
first it starts with them lead by
example they got lead by example and if
they're not sure about their money they
don't have a plan then when they talk to
the kids kids can sense that they're a
little shaky on what they're saying that
they don't really believe what they're
saying or they're really doing it so
they have to have that conviction inside
that's what causes true change and
that's how I believe we change
Generations is we we we work with these
parents these families and we help them
to be as successful as they can because
just by their example and them being
comfortable with their money now and not
being afraid now they can have those
honest conversations at the kitchen
table that I would never be able to have
with with their children right right in
my experience uh on the planet all the
years I've been on the planet uh
consumerism I think is like at an
all-time high it just seems like you
know there's there's just more and more
stuff constantly coming at you that you
can buy and a phenomenon over the past
years uh for gift giving uh when I was a
kid and I can remember these clearly i'
get I you know my birthday I you from my
aunts you know uncles whatever you know
I'd open it up and it'd be there's some
cash in there lot and I even remember
the envelopes with the little thing cut
out with the head you know I'd see the
face of uh whoever the president was and
I know what it was without seeing the
number yeah I remember those yeah so so
you know that was and and I kept a
little safe where I stored all my cash
but now it's it's like hey a gift card
to Best Buy a gift card to Star which
means that you you literally got a gift
that requires you to consume that you
can't save you can't invest what have
you what's your view on that you know
it's so hard to fight the marketing
dollars of these multi-billion
multi-national companies like you go to
Starbucks there's all the gift cards
there right Best Buy when you check out
gift cards Amazon gift cards everyone's
getting it so instead of trying to fight
that battle let's play along with it and
so what I do personally for my kids and
some of my key people is I give them
gift cards to invest in stocks is it
such a thing there is so there's just
really cool app this company called
stockpile and I love them I I have all
my kids with a stockpile account I even
have one personally because I wanted to
do it myself and they have these cool
gift cards so uh this was a couple
Christmases ago I bought gift cards so I
bought like $100 of Tesla stock for this
son right he's he likes cards and I
bought $100 of Disney for my daughter I
bought $100 of Apple for my other son
and so for each kid I got different
stocks and it comes in a gift card and
so they see it has the logos on it
everything and you take it to the app
and you go and upload the money and you
start to track your Investments so we
started with a few hundred doll with my
kids just recently and we we've been
putting their money in there and they
get to see it every day it's so simple
and they track it and we look at it all
the time and then and then we we taught
our kids to say hey we're going to put
some of your money in there and I want
you to find three really good companies
that you can invest in that you think is
going to be solid so they know things
that I don't about different companies
right right and so I had a daughter that
that picked um Urban Outfitters I'm like
what is Urban Outfitters like a hiking
like no that it's a clothing company
like why did you pick that well because
all the teenagers buy clothes they're
okay well good so put some of your money
in there and then my kids bought apple
and and Disney because they start to see
the trend with possibly going to a
Disney plus this was a couple years ago
and now their Disney stock is just taken
off and they of course they love apple
and they're tracking all this and it's
getting getting them to talk about it
and it's has it gives us something to
communicate with with them when it comes
to money and here's the cool thing is
they can actually trade that the trades
are like 99 Cents so it's very minimal
they can buy and sell stock but what
happens is when they do either one they
buy or sell a stock it sends me a
notification via email to approve it or
not oh wow so I'm getting these email
messages like during school hours I'm
like calling my son like dude are you
trading stocks during school like Dad
Dad it dropped yeah good boy dad the
stock dropped like okay good CU when
everybody else is selling when the stock
drops we're buying so when it goes red
that's when we look to buy when it goes
green Let It Go just Let it keep riding
well it's and what's the name of that
gift card again stockpile stockpile it's
an app yeah you can buy the their gift
cards and they even have them at like a
few like grocery stores I think they had
it like yeah grocery St a brilliant idea
rather than say you give you a gift that
makes you a consumer give you a gift
that makes you an investor you're
consuming stock that's what we're
doing I love it it's a good one and I
love the fact that you're you're find
half your kids are trading while they're
at school oh yeah I was a proud daddy I
think my wife was a little Disturbed
that they were doing it during math or
whatever but hey what do you say I think
that's terrific what are the majority of
your activities today directed it you
know my my passion I have a hard time
sleeping I'm always thinking about
personal finance how can I help more
people there's such a need out there for
financial education in families that can
that can change your lives like how I
Chang mine I changed my entire family's
life for Generations now because I
decide to make a stand I decided to
learn about the basics of money and
that's that's my I I'm I'm totally
consumed with that now and how do we
help more people worldwide that have
that same problem I mean you see the
effects it's it's out there and and for
me I'm in a different Financial space
now I live in different neighborhoods
now but I never ever forget where I came
from never ever and that those humble
roots of where I came from keeps me
grounded and keeps me working hard so in
spreading Financial uh education in the
way that you're doing it is this uh
something that you have maybe some ideas
about as far as saying you want to move
into specific areas uh of cultures or
communities to bring to or is it matter
just whatever comes to you or you what's
your plan so we started in Hawaii um in
2002 so just as this of of this filming
we're over 17 years
now and uh We've helped out over 30,000
families across the country and uh our
job is to continue to do that and
continue to look for innovative ways to
find and teach um one of the challenges
for our company as far as growth but
it's actually a beautiful thing is we're
actually in what we call the trenches so
every family that we work with we're
actually sitting on their kitchen table
with them either in person if we have an
instructor there or on their kitchen
table via a a zoom or something but
we're personally walking them through it
now it's much more difficult to really
scale that way because it's Hands-On but
it's truly one of the only ways that it
can work any particular uh stories that
inspired you uh you know with some of
the some of the transs I or
Transformations that you've seen happen
as people are going through this process
yeah so there was this young couple on
on the big have you ever been to Kona
con I've never been to Kona beautiful
beautiful place and um so this this
young couple Shan and capena um they had
twins while they were in high school M
he was 15 I think she was 17 wow they
had four kids before they were 20 wow
and so when I had met them they were
living in public subsidized housing
they're paying $74 a month in uh in rent
um they came to one of my classes and
they said you know what I think we need
that and we started teaching them and
this was just over 11 years
ago um first thing we did is we helped
them to get out of their Consumer Debt
$40,000 in Consumer Debt we helped them
to get rid of that in about 18 to 20
months then our plan was to help them to
buy a home which which they did about a
year later they saved it for a down
payment they got home today I'm very
very happy to report that they are on
their 11th house wow they're on their
11th house all in Kona they became
investors they saw they could do it one
property and they did another and
another and I was just there a couple
months ago and they took me on on a
little tour of their new lot so they
they bought a 5 acre lot that just
overlooks the ocean there on the side of
the
volcano um and it it overlooks the ocean
it's beautiful and their their family's
lives have changed and they they the two
twins that they had in high school ended
up going to some amazing colleges
they're in college uh one in Paris and
one in
Philadelphia what amazing uh the
statistics on um a 17 and a 15-year-old
who have a child absolutely you know uh
them ever getting to any semblance of
non-dependence and never mind being able
to you know like pay their own bills or
generate wealth but you know to actually
not even be dependent on on the system
the chances of that happening are so so
remote yeah typically families like that
will be on government assistance for
quite some time yeah so is it your
premise that literally those statistics
can be absolutely like blown apart just
through some education I mean is there
something that's uniquely special I
guess is what I'm asking is something
uniquely special about that couple or is
it just a matter that if you have the
desire and You' B to learn you can do
this I believe in financial education
for everyone everyone deserves that
chance to be educated so they can make
the decision decisions for themselves
whether they're motivated or not we
should give them that opportunity to
learn and those that want to do it just
like anything in life they will do it
but those that don't then they will
obviously get what they are working for
but but everyone needs a chance to learn
so they they all have that equal
opportunity to have a shot at Building
Wealth and uh and that's the goal the
goal is for them to build self-
sustaining wealth but the first step is
we got to get your financial life
together well Alan this is uh one of the
most inspiring and fun conversations you
know that I've ever had uh just seeing
you know your own story um seeing how
you stay connected to your roots but
have a vision for a future and how
you're trying to lift a bunch of other
people out of financial stress and give
them a better life it's it's a really
noble noble thing and I appreciate you
taking the time to sit and and share
that with us thank you Patrick I
appreciate what you and Jeff are doing
to to create these series to share with
the world as part of that Financial
literacy movement that I've been a part
of for over 17 years so I thank you for
everything you're doing and I appreciate
it and uh a big Mahalo to you thank you
to see the next episode in the wealth
breakthrough series check the video
right there next to me I think you'll
love it continue to believe and I'll see
you there often you have to kind of look
around at your life and look at the
people who are succeeding in what you
want to do and you have to say to
yourself I want to find out how the best
in the world get to be great